Ah ja, heute bin ich relativ früh, 8.35 Uhr, glaub so früh war ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Force Champ, kann ich auch früher was futtern gehen.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was es heute wieder gibt, wobei, gibt's heute gar nicht, gibt's heute was anderes.
Ja, aber Nudeln gibt's, richtig.
Das ist eigentlich fast immer das gleiche.
Nudeln gibt's, aber es gibt nicht Lachs, sondern es gibt, ähm, was gibt's denn?
Ich glaub einfach nur Tomatensauce und Hackfleisch dabei.
Spaghetti, wisst ihr übrigens, das haben wir gar nicht on stream gemacht, aber ich hab mir doch so einen smarten Pet Fountain gekauft.
Also einen smarten Katzen, smarter Katzenbrunnen.
Ja, sowas hier.
Haben wir doch on stream gefunden, das Ding, und ich hab gesagt, ich bestell das und probier's mal aus.
Also ich hab's nicht, wir haben's nicht on stream ausprobiert, aber ich hab's mittlerweile ausprobiert.
Und es lässt sich wirklich ganz brauchbar in Home Assistant und Smart Home Sachen integrieren.
Leider, also es gibt zwei Negativpunkte.
Man braucht einen Mi Home Account, leider, leider.
Ja, also man braucht einen Mi Home Account, das ist, und es gibt leider auch keine Custom Firmware oder sowas dafür.
Und das Ding braucht ab und zu mal Internet Access, damit das funktioniert.
Also das ist ziemlich blöd.
Auf der anderen Seite hab ich den Kram eher in einem eigenen WLAN drin stehen, was eigentlich sonst nirgends wohin darf.
Ist aber trotzdem doof, dass man quasi einen Always On Zwang hat in so einem Smart Home Gerät.
Aber man kann es rein lokal steuern, auch wenn das Internet nicht geht.
Das braucht nur mal kurz Internet, wenn es bootet.
Sonst nicht.
Was aber auch schon irgendwie ziemlich bescheuert ist.
Aber zumindest, ich kann jetzt über meinen Smart Home, kann ich den jetzt ein- und ausschalten.
Und dann sieht man auch so Sachen wie Filter muss getauscht werden und solche Geschichten.
Also ehrlich gesagt, eigentlich ist die Smart Home Integration einfach nur nice to have, braucht man nicht.
Funktioniert aber ganz gut.
Aber Chico mag die anderen Brunnen mehr.
Den find's irgendwie nicht so geil, obwohl es der teuerste ist.
Ich mein, Chico hat eh Luxus.
Chico hat drei Brunnen, darf laufend an Wasserhahnen und da trinken, hat drei Klos.
Also Chico kann wirklich überall trinken und überall kacken, wo sie will.
Die hat nen Klo, die hat nen Klo im Erdgeschoss, Klo im ersten Stock, Klo im Hof.
Brunnen erster Stock, Brunnen zweiter, Brunnen Erdgeschoss, Brunnen erster Stock.
Und noch da, wo sie meistens rumliegt.
Wozu muss der smart sein?
Ja, müssen muss der nicht.
Also was es bringt ist, du kannst den ein- und ausschalten.
Remote, über die App oder halt über das Smart Home System, wo du das integriert hast.
Also die Pumpe kannst du ein- und ausschalten.
Was nicht verkehrt ist, weil mir ist schon öfters mal die Pumpe kaputt gegangen bei den anderen.
Man würde zwar davon ausgehen, die sind für 24-7 Betrieb ausgelegt, aber die geben oftmals so nach 2-3 Jahren den Geist auf.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht, dass man die ausschalten kann.
Weil das muss ja auch nur angehen, wenn die in der Power Saving, so viel braucht das Ding nicht.
Aber es muss ja auch nur wirklich an sein, wenn die Katze da längere Zeit rumchillt in der Nähe.
Also man kann das ein- und ausschalten.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Und man bekommt mit, wenn das Ding der Meinung ist, es müssen Filter gewechselt werden und sowas.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, die sind ja der Meinung, man soll einmal alle 30 Tage die Sachen da drin wechseln.
Das mache ich nicht.
Einmal alle 30 Tage ist einfach viel zu heftig.
Dann bezahlst du dich ja auch dumm und dämlich.
Braucht man ja auch nicht.
Also das ist, das ist übertrieben.
Aber wenn man so mal alle 2-3, also alle 3 Monate mal wechselt, ist auch okay.
Was soll das groß filtern?
Im Zweifelsfall verstopfst du es, aber dann merkst du es auch.
Also das muss man nicht so übertrieben oft wechseln.
Aber es ist ganz praktisch.
Ansonsten, naja.
Das Geld kann man auch besser investieren.
60€ sind immerhin 60€.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ein normaler Brunnen für 15€ tut es auch.
Erkennt er, wenn das Wasser leer ist?
Relativ sicher, ja.
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber ich glaube schon.
Der hat auch verschiedene Statusanzeigen hier vorne.
Ja doch, natürlich erkennt er das, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Das hatte ich letztens erst, da habe ich es nicht richtig reingemacht.
Dann leuchtet es hier vorne gelb oder orange.
Wenn das irgendwie Probleme mit der Wasserzufuhr oder der Pumpe hat.
Und wahrscheinlich kriegt man das auch über Error mit im Smart Home.
Da habe ich aber nicht geguckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber das hat verschiedene Sensoren.
Und ich denke, dass man auch einen Error mitbekommt.
Aber das Wasser wird ja eigentlich bei diesen Brunnen nie wirklich leer.
So viel saufen die Katzen nicht.
Das ist immer genug da.
Und irgendwann läuft es nicht mehr richtig.
Das hörst du dann auch, weil die Brunnen komische Geräusche machen.
Wenn sie nicht richtig voll sind.
Also die Pumpe besser gesagt macht komische Geräusche.
URLs werden aus dem Chat gelöscht.
Nee.
Warum sollten die gelöscht werden?
Du siehst doch, hier sind sie doch noch.
Senior C-Sharp Developer.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, schon mal geguckt.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die Videos werden einem ja total oft vorgeschlagen.
Weil die denken, ich bin voll die Zielgruppe dafür.
Ich muss sagen, die meisten finde ich nicht lustig.
Ein paar sind ganz witzig.
Aber die meisten sind irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, lame.
Irgendwie finde ich die nicht toll.
Obwohl wir genau die Zielgruppe eigentlich sind dafür.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Das muss jetzt einfach mal sein, Chat.
Das ist so dumm, Alter.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Das wurde mir heute Morgen mal wieder empfohlen auf YouTube.
Das muss jetzt ein Durchgang sein.
Ich sag doch, wir kriegen total viel vorgeschlagen in dieser Richtung.
An Videos.
Und wie gesagt, die meisten finde ich nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ja gut.
Wenn das Bild schon klein werden soll, dann JPG.
Und wenn es gut aussehen soll, dann PNG.
Wobei wahrscheinlich PNG auch irgendeinen Kompressionsmodus kann.
Aber fragt mich nicht.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Ich krieg sowas empfohlen auf YouTube.
Sagst du das jetzt, weil ich letztens erzählt habe,
dass ich das Blödsinn finde, das so auszusprechen?
Oder sprichst du das wirklich so aus?
Also, ganz kurz.
Das Problem war folgendes.
Wir machen jetzt 20, 30 Sekunden.
Na gut, ganz kurz krieg ich es nicht hin.
Also, CubeCTL ruft GKE, ruft Google Authentifizierungsplugin auf.
Google Authentifizierungsplugin ruft Google Command-Line-Tool auf.
Google Command-Line-Tool versucht ins Internet zu gehen.
GStatic.com sich eine Datei abzurufen, damit es überprüfen kann,
ob die Version richtig ist.
Ob die Version aktuell ist.
Der Server kommt nicht ins Internet.
Deswegen hängt das Ganze an der Stelle zwei Minuten,
weil es unter der Haube die Curl-Library verwendet
und Packages ins Internet getroppt und nicht rejected werden.
Und deswegen hängt es alle 15 Minuten für zwei Minuten.
Twitter ist die DOSing itself.
Äh, ist die DOSing itself.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Warum die DOSt sich Twitter selbst?
Oh.
Ist das dieses Macedon von dem alle, was keiner benutzt?
Ja gut, ich kenn das natürlich, aber...
Bis gestern, bis gestern hab ich immer noch gedacht, das wird nix.
Weil einfach die kritische Masse fehlt.
Aber wenn Twitter jetzt anfängt, User einfach auszusperren,
das Verlinken nicht mehr richtig möglich zu machen,
ohne Geld zu bezahlen, Twitter nicht mehr zu benutzen,
dann vielleicht, also dann könnte tatsächlich das Beste,
was die machen könnten, dass Leute zu ihnen kommen,
von Twitter selbst ausgehen und nicht, weil sie so toll sind.
Okay, this is hilarious.
Twitter ist die DOSing itself.
Okay.
Twitter is firing off about 10 requests a second to itself
to try and fetch content that never arrives.
Okay.
Tja.
Ja gut, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen das Problem,
wenn du die Hälfte der Leute rausschmeißt,
die wissen, wie die Sachen funktionieren, ne?
Ach.
Also ich glaube, da werden sie wieder zurückrudern müssen,
was diese Blogsachen angeht.
Das nimmt einfach viel zu...
Hab ich ja gestern mich schon ausführlich zu ausgelassen im Stream.
Das nimmt, glaube ich, Twitter einfach zu viel Relevanz.
Und letztendlich auch zu viel Werbeanzeigen und so.
Also das glaube ich nicht.
Äh, das, das...
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
ob JPG Transparenz kann.
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Aber es kann schon sein, dass das nicht kann, ja.
Ach, du hast das so geschrieben?
Diktierfunktion am Fernsehen.
Krass, Alter, was es nicht alles gibt.
JPG kann kein Alpha-Channel, also keine Transparenz.
Okay, ja, dann muss man PNG benutzen dafür.
Oder, oder GIF.
Oder, oder GIF, wie es manche Leute nennen.
Oder JPG 2000 oder so,
was es mal da als Alternativformate gab,
was sich nie durchgesetzt hat.
Oder Webm.
Webm.
Kann Webm Transparenz?
Wahrscheinlich kann Webm Transparenz...
Nee, nee, nicht Webm.
Webm ist es ja.
Webm ist ja das Video.
Und Webm...
...ist das Bild.
Wobei das auch, glaube ich,
nicht so wirklich alles richtig unterstützt.
Oder auch nicht alle Browser
das jetzt noch komplett unterstützen.
Also was mich immer noch wundert,
ist, dass FFmpeg kein Webm kann.
Und kein Webm...
Webm kann FFmpeg nicht konvertieren.
Was ziemlich sagt.
Wenn man beispielsweise Bilder runterlädt in Webm
und will das irgendwie konvertieren,
dann geht das nicht.
Weil FFmpeg kein Webm kann.
Scheiß Formatname.
Es wird auch, ehrlich gesagt,
mal wieder Zeit für ein neues Imageformat.
Video weniger, aber neues Imageformat.
Weil PNG und JPG,
die Dinger sind irgendwie 20 Jahre alt.
Dann kam PNG raus 1996,
JPG ist noch ein bisschen älter.
Weiß man, das ist so alt.
1992, lul.
Ich meine, JPG komprimiert halt, glaube ich, besser
und kann auch Bilder kleiner machen.
Ich bin, was diese Sachen angeht,
ehrlich gesagt, nicht so drin.
Ich benutze meistens, wenn ich Bilder brauche,
einfach PNG und fertig.
Aber ich mache ja auch keine größeren Webseiten,
wo sich auf Imagecontent fokussiert wird.
Vielleicht wäre das auch nicht an allen Stellen sinnvoll.
Ich meine, PNG ist, glaube ich,
potenziell einfach ein bisschen größer.
Oder was, ein bisschen, eine ganze Ecke größer.
TIFF.
Ja, warum nicht alles gleich direkt BMP, Bitmap,
RGBA Bitmaps,
die dann erst mal 3,5G groß sind
für ein ordentliches Bild,
für irgendein 4K-Foto.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht,
wie groß RAW Bitmap-Sachen sind.
Image Magic kann es, okay.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass Image Magic
gar nicht mehr,
wird das überhaupt noch weiterentwickelt?
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ja, und tatsächlich auch ziemlich aktuell
und ziemlich viel auch, ja.
Also mehr als...
mehr als meine GitHub-Projekte, ja.
Was ist eigentlich JFEF?
Auch irgendein Imageformat,
aber fragt mich please nicht, welches.
Oder ist es...
Nee, das ist, glaube ich,
das ist auch irgendein Imageformat.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, es ist relativ einfach.
What is...
Wir fragen einfach mal Google, was es ist.
Okay, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Das JPEG-File-Interchange-Format.
1991.
Okay, jetzt geht es aber los.
Entwickel es,
die nach JPEG-Norm komprimiert werden als...
Ähm, ist das das Gleiche?
Ach, das ist einfach nur der Name
und damit ist der Name nicht automatisch
die Technologie quasi oder die Dateikürzel.
Also sprich, das Ding nennt sich so
und die Leute kürzen es JPEG und JPG.
Ach so.
Ja, ach so.
Aha.
Also ist das Gleiche.
Bist du wieder was gelernt, Jul?
Bei der Gelegenheit,
wenn wir gerade auf GitHub sind,
lasst uns doch mal gucken, was trendet.
Außer...
Außer AI.
Äh, wo ist es denn?
Ach da, Trending.
Was trendet denn?
PowerShell!
Was ist das denn?
Warum, warum trendet PowerShell?
Geh mal bloß weg.
Ich mein, PowerShell ist nicht schlecht,
aber mit PowerShell würde ich nicht arbeiten wollen.
PowerShell ist nice,
wenn du Sachen automatisieren willst unter Windows,
aber nicht so zum interaktiven Benutzen,
das ist abartig.
Aber okay, ich verstehe die Existenzberechtigung von PowerShell,
okay, aber benutzen will ich es nicht.
Ich hab ernsthaft keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll vom Projekttitel her.
Der kann...
No, äh, ist das ein Notizprogramm?
Oder was soll das sein?
Hä?
Nee, so Draw.io oder so.
Nee, doch ein Notizprogramm.
Hä, okay.
Ja, wir haben unbedingt noch 50 Milliarden mehr Notizprogramme gebraucht.
C++ Library.
Ja, das gibt's schon eine Weile.
Aber sind weniger AI-Projekte drin, oder?
Die ersten 5 Projekte und kein AI davon.
Was ist da los?
Ach, ich bin auf Today und nicht auf Week.
Deswegen...
Die Idee hinter PowerShell finde ich auch nice,
aber ich glaube einfach,
dass dieser Ansatz sich viel mehr eignet,
um längere Sachen zu scripten und zu automatisieren,
als zum interaktiv Arbeiten.
Zum interaktiv Arbeiten finde ich den Ansatz,
dass einfach In- und Output ganz normaler Text ist,
einfacher im Hirn durchzusteigen.
Und für kurze Scripting-Automatisierung-Sachen auch.
Wenn es dann komplizierter wird,
dann ist sicherlich PowerShell und gerade mit Windows-Bezug schon sinnvoll.
Aber ich hätte trotzdem keinen Bock drauf.
Das haben wir mal ausprobiert, hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
China-Chinesen-Machine-Learning.
Machine-Learning, Machine-Learning.
Leute, das beste GitHub-Projekt ist ja immer noch
Anime-Girls-Holding-Programming-Books.
Also wenn einer das absolute Vorzeige-GitHub-Projekt
irgendwo mal erwähnen muss, so nach dem Motto,
dafür ist GitHub gemacht worden, ja,
dann müsst ihr das aufmachen.
ABAP.
Ja.
Dann kriegt man dann...
Ich hoffe, es ist kein TOS.
Da gibt's doch solche...
Dafür steht GitHub mit seinem Namen, genau.
Ist heute nur die Frage, ob Weeps In oder Weeps Out.
Okay, nix Spannendes dabei.
Wir gehen mal auf die Woche,
weil da ist das meistens ein bisschen aussagekräftiger.
AI, AI, Svelte.
Ja gut, da kam erst Version 4 raus, vollkommen zurecht.
Wenn ihr mich fragt von der Handhabung her
und alles das Gesamtpaket, das ist das beste Frontend-Framework,
auch wenn es eigentlich...
Jetzt kommen die Svelte-Kenner und sagen,
actually ist das ja eigentlich gar kein Frontend-Framework,
sondern ein JavaScript-Compiler.
Aber letztendlich, du kannst es benutzen,
wie die meisten Frontend-Frameworks.
Und ist auch ziemlich angenehm.
Also, wenn ihr mich fragt, ich mache am liebsten Web-Apps damit.
Allerdings im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld
ist natürlich React immer noch ungeschlagen.
Auch von der Verbreitung und den Libraries
und dem ganzen Ökosystem drumherum.
Ich skippe mal alle AI-Geschichten, ja.
SpaceDrive ist ein Open-Source-Cross-Plot.
Achso, File-Export haben wir schon mal gesehen.
Das ist die ursprüngliche Awesome-List.
Die gibt es auch schon irgendwie 15 Jahre oder so.
Ja gut, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben,
so lange gibt es noch kein GitHub.
Horeshell, Trended, Clean Architecture.
Das ist so ein bisschen was, wo man sieht,
dass die Sharp-Entwickler eigentlich
so vom gleichen Schlag sind wie Java-Entwickler
und alles extrem kompliziert machen müssen.
Ich sage nicht, dass das nicht seinen Sinn hätte
oder zumindest Ansätze davon ganz nice sind,
aber wenn ich mir teilweise YouTube-Videos angucke,
wo hier propagiert wird,
immer alles schön clean Architecture und sonst was,
da hast du eine Funktionalität von drei Zeilen,
aber du musst erst mal fünf Interfaces,
drei Services und fünf Controller und alles definieren,
damit du das machen kannst.
Also die übertreiben ist teilweise einfach maßlos.
Also das krasseste, was ich gesehen habe,
wo irgendjemand in einem Talk meinte,
man verwendet kein DateTime,
sondern man macht ein IDateTime-Interface davon.
Was in manchen Fällen, um das zu testen,
sicherlich sinnvoll sein kann,
aber so pauschal ist das halt komplett unsinnig.
Und es macht schon durchaus Sinn,
weil Microsoft mittlerweile ja selbst
sowas ähnliches mitliefert bald.
Naja, aber das ist total übertrieben an vielen Stellen.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
okay, ich muss das revidieren.
Kann ich pauschal sagen, dass das total übertrieben ist.
Für kleine Sachen ist das total übertrieben.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie eine super komplexe
Business-Enterprise-Anwendung hat,
wo mehrere Leute dran arbeiten
und die auch auf absehbare Zeit
maintained werden muss für ein paar Jahre,
da kann das durchaus Sinn machen,
Teile davon zu nehmen.
Man muss ja nicht einfach blind alles umsetzen,
weil irgendjemand gesagt hat,
clean architecture, so muss es sein.
Was sagst du zu 100% Testabdeckung?
Braucht man nicht.
Tests braucht man prinzipiell eh nur,
wenn man Mist baut.
Und nachdem ja gute Leute keinen Mist bauen,
braucht man auch keine Tests.
Nee, aber ernsthaft.
Also 100% Testabdeckung ist utopisch.
Ich glaube, man muss einen guten Kompromiss finden.
Wo sich das lohnt.
Ich finde, man muss auch nicht
Tests schreiben, nur um Tests zu haben,
so an manchen Stellen.
Vor allem, wenn es dann darauf ausartet,
dass man so unsinnige Tests hat,
wo jedes Mal, wenn sich die Funktionalität ändert,
auch die Tests angepasst, oder was?
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Nicht, wenn sich die Funktion...
Doch, dass du jedes Mal die Tests ändern musst,
dass sie wieder grün sind,
wenn du was umgebaut hast.
Ja, manchmal mag das sicherlich so sein,
aber wenn du Comments siehst,
die quasi zur Hälfte immer Testanpassungen enthalten,
dass das Neue funktioniert,
ist halt die Frage,
was mit den ursprünglichen Tests eigentlich los gewesen ist.
Nee, also 100% Testabdeckung finde ich utopisch.
Ich glaube, man muss sich die Stellen raussuchen.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es unsinnig ist.
Je nachdem, was du machst.
Es muss halt irgendwie,
wie bei vielem,
es muss halt irgendwie passen.
Also, was ich halt nur nicht gut finde,
sind so Policies.
Das sage ich als jemand,
der nicht hauptberuflich ein Softwareentwickler ist,
wohlgemerkt.
Es muss halt...
Es muss halt passen zu dem, was man machen will.
Und man sollte es nach Möglichkeit nicht pauschalisieren.
So nach dem Motto,
bevor du das machen darfst,
muss immer ein Test existieren und sowas.
So pauschale...
Es ist ja gut,
wenn es irgendwelche Guidelines gibt und solche Geschichten.
Aber so Pauschalisierungen
beißen sich dann meistens selbst in den Schwanz,
an Stellen, wo man halt an Sonderfälle nicht gedacht hat.
Zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel,
keine Ahnung,
du musst mit irgendeinem
proprietären
Webservice kommunizieren.
Oder ich kann dir mal ein Beispiel,
ich kann mal ein Beispiel erzählen.
Wo das mit Testabdeckung teilweise echt gar nicht so einfach gewesen ist.
Und zwar...
Ja.
Ja genau.
Es macht ja auch durchaus Sinn,
gerade wenn alle Teile davon in deiner Hand liegen,
ist das ja wieder was ganz anderes.
Also nur mal ein Beispiel,
wo das schwierig ist mit Tests allgemein.
Und zwar,
wenn man Services benutzt,
auf die man keinen Einfluss hat,
beziehungsweise
es auch nicht klar dokumentiert ist,
wie diese Services funktionieren.
Wir nehmen mal ein Beispiel aus einem Projekt von mir.
Das ist ein Addon für Home Assistant,
was die inoffizielle API von Fiat benutzt,
um Informationen über dem,
über das Elektroauto,
was man mit dem Account verknüpft hat,
abzufragen.
Ja, da kannst du so Sachen abfragen,
wie ist die Batterieladung,
der Ladestand,
der aktuelle,
wie nennt sich das,
Ottometer, glaube ich, Ger?
Offiziell?
Heißt das nicht Ottometer?
Also quasi,
wieviel du gefahren bist seit dem letzten Geset.
Kilometerzähler.
Dann siehst du den Standort
und kannst Reifendruck und sowas sehen.
Also kannst,
ja und du siehst auch hier,
wann du geladen hast.
Zumindest,
du kannst Informationen über dein Elektroauto abfragen.
So.
Das Problem ist jetzt,
das benutzt ein Service von Fiat.
Der Service von Fiat,
der ist teilweise reverse-engineert worden,
aber es hat keiner eine Ahnung,
wie der eigentlich genau funktioniert.
Und damit das,
damit man überhaupt was Nennenswertes machen kann,
muss man sich halt zu diesem Service connecten.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage,
wie will man das gescheitestens,
wie will man das,
wie will man das gescheitestbar machen?
Ich hab's probiert.
Ich hab so einen,
ich hab quasi mal die Response genommen von diesem Service,
so dass ich mich nicht jedes Mal anmelden muss.
Also ich hab quasi das genommen,
was das Service zurückgibt
und hab das ein bisschen customised
und halt hier in so eine,
zum Testen halt offline mäßig mal reingehauen.
Das Problem ist,
du kannst es nicht wirklich unabhängig davon testen,
weil du nicht weißt,
was das macht.
Also du weißt nicht,
was sind die möglichen Antworten von diesem Service.
Beispielsweise,
was sind die möglichen Parameter innerhalb von Fuel?
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was da alles zurückkommen kann.
Deswegen kann ich auch nur schwer testen,
dass meine Logik,
die das Ganze verarbeitet,
funktioniert,
wenn da irgendwie jetzt
auch noch zusätzlich Energy anstatt Fuel oder was auch immer
abgefragt werden soll.
Ich mein, ich kann testen,
dass es einen Fehler gibt,
wenn da nicht Fuel steht oder sowas.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel,
wenn dieser Value auf einmal ein Int anstatt String ist,
ist das wirklich ein Testfall?
Ich kann ja schlecht alles Eventuelle,
was irgendwie sein könnte, testen.
Ich kann mir überlegen,
es könnte durchaus sein,
dass es hier noch mehrere Einträge gibt.
Vielleicht sollte ich nicht das Hard Coden
auf das erste Array Element oder sowas in der Richtung.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal überprüfen.
Aber es ist immer schwer,
Sachen zu testen, wo man nicht genau weiß,
was man eigentlich da testen muss.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Also das werde ich nie ordentlich machen können.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt zu übergegangen,
um das zu testen.
So einfache Sachen,
ob sie prinzipiell funktionieren,
halt mit so einem Offline-Mock,
der Mock-Champ ist unterwegs,
auszuprobieren.
Und alles andere habe ich mir einfach noch
einen Fake-Account gemacht bei Fiat,
dass ich nicht so oft ins Rate-Limit laufe.
Und alle Sachen,
wo man nicht direkt eine ID vom Auto braucht,
mache ich halt da drüber.
Und ansonsten nehme ich halt meinen echten Account.
Es ist halt schwierig, was zu testen, ja.
Ja, solche Sachen kann ich ausprobieren,
aber ich kann halt nie ausprobieren,
ob das wirklich dann am Ende auch so kommt,
ob das tut.
Weil eine Änderung bei mir, die ich mache,
kann ja wunderbar funktionieren,
aber wenn Fiat sich in zwei Wochen denkt,
ah, da kommt jetzt irgendwie noch was extra an das mit rein,
dann kann sein, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Ja, ich kann alles,
was in meiner Hoheit ist, ausprobieren,
aber nachdem ich keine AP-Dokumentation habe
von dem Service,
kann ich auch keinen Fake-Service bauen so richtig,
um ordentlich testen zu können.
Oh, Stream-Titel nicht geändert, oh.
Du hast recht.
Chat-Gil, warum sagt denn das keiner?
Aufwachen-Stream.
Also ihr müsst das immer,
und das muss ich jetzt auch mal dazu sagen,
ihr müsst das ja immer mit einer Portion Vorsicht genießen,
wenn ich euch sowas erzähle, ne.
Ich spreche da nicht mit 15 Jahren Software,
hauptberufliche Software-Entwickler-Perspektive,
sondern als jemand,
der ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat,
interne Tools entwickelt hat
und sich auch sonst dafür interessiert
und auch ein paar Open-Source-Projekte hat.
Aber ich bin kein Architekt
oder wie gesagt hauptberufliche Software-Entwickler.
Das kann durchaus sein,
dass wenn man Sachen im Team entwickelt,
wenn das super komplexe Enterprise-Business-Sachen sind,
dass das sich da anders verhält,
als das, was ich euch dann erzähle, ne.
Also, inwiefern sollte man sein Frontend testen?
Im Backend macht das ja irgendwie Sinn für mich,
aber im Frontend scheint es einfach nur unglaublich viel Overhead.
Einmal sage ich ja immer, wenn das ein, ja.
Das ist jetzt so ein Ding,
wo ich wenig zu sagen kann.
Ich teste meine Frontends gar nicht.
Aber,
insgesamt würde ich nicht sagen,
dass das die beste Idee ist.
Du hast ja grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene Arten,
wie man testen kann.
Oder du hast noch mehrere Arten,
aber ich würde mal sagen,
so grundsätzlich zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Du kannst entweder deine Funktionalität prüfen.
Sag mal, du hast eine Funktion,
die bekommt drei Parameter
und du rufst die Funktion dann halt
mit unterschiedlichen Parametern an.
Und guckst, ob sie das macht,
beziehungsweise das zurückgibt,
was du erwartest.
Das ist das eine, so.
Und du kannst die komplette Anwendung nehmen
und irgendjemand vorsetzen und sag,
mach mal, oder guck mal, dass das noch funktioniert.
Oder guck mal, dass dieses Feature
sich auch so verhält wie gedacht.
Das sind ja so zwei grundsätzliche Ansätze beim Testen.
Und bei Frontends,
gerade wenn das ein Frontend ist,
was tatsächlich auch von vielen,
von vielen Endanwendern benutzt wird,
ist das zweite wahrscheinlich der sinnvollere Fall.
Und sollte man auf jeden Fall machen,
wenn es ein größeres Release von einer Anwendung ist,
die viele Leute benutzen.
Also man sollte es auf jeden Fall mal Testern geben.
Und nicht Programmierern geben,
die da ein bisschen rumklicken und genau wissen.
Sondern man sollte es Testern geben
und sagen, guck mal, ob das noch so funktioniert wie gedacht.
Es gibt Leute, die haben da so ein Händchen für,
die finden genau das, was nicht funktioniert.
Beziehungsweise ist auch wichtig,
die Information hier,
und das nervt mich jetzt an der Stelle,
da weiß ich nicht, was ich machen soll.
Wenn man keine Tester hat,
es gibt einen Trick,
wie man doch testen kann,
ohne Tester zu haben.
Und zwar, man kann
die neue Version deployen.
Allerdings stellt man ein,
dass sowohl die alte als auch die neue Version aktiv sind.
Und dann liefert man, sagen wir mal, an 1%,
das sieht man beispielsweise
bei YouTube und Twitter öfters mal.
Und dann liefert man an 1% der User
mal die neue Version aus
oder das neue Feature aus.
Und guckt man, ob sich welche beschweren.
Und dann wartest du mal eine Weile
und wenn sich keine beschweren,
oder wenn sich wenige beschweren,
oder du die Sache ein bisschen gefixt hast
und die Beschwerden nachlassen,
dann lässt es auf mehr Leute los.
Das sieht man bei YouTube und bei Twitter
und bestimmt bei anderen Services,
aber bei YouTube und Twitter ist es mir besonders aufgefallen.
Bei YouTube im Besonderen,
öfters,
dass neue Designversuche
oftmals nur einen kleinen Teil der User bekommen
und dass es teilweise Wochen und Monate dauert.
Oftmals wirklich Monate,
bis dann alle
letztendlich die Sachen haben.
Ja, habe ich, habe ich.
Vielleicht spielen wir heute Abend sogar noch eine Runde
im Stream wieder.
Also, ich werde erst mal ein bisschen
Offstream einspielen,
aber vielleicht spielen wir heute Abend noch ein paar Runden.
Ja, also das ist so das Ding,
was sich anbietet,
wenn man keine Tester in dem Sinn hat,
aber trotzdem testen will.
Du deployst das mal
und lässt dann halt die Anwender,
paar Prozente der Anwender das Neue benutzen
und guckst, ob die sich beschweren.
Bei YouTube sieht man es öfters,
von Designänderungen bis irgendwelche neuen Buttons
bis irgendwie nur noch drei Zeilen in der Beschreibung
im Creator-Dashboard und sowas.
Ja, da wäre ein Test mal gut.
Aber ich gehe immer noch davon aus,
dass das kein Test ist,
weil das nimmt so viel Relevanz von Twitter weg.
Das kommt drauf an.
Also es wird sicherlich ein Teil,
also ich denke so,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die es machen.
Ich könnte mir das nur,
ich kann mir da nur was zusammenreimen.
Aber ich denke mal,
der Großteil wird wirklich random sein.
Allerdings kann man sich ja auch opt-in
als Versuchskaninchen bei Google und YouTube irgendwo,
weiß gar nicht wo, aber es geht.
Und dass das dann dort halt
vornehmlich halt diese Leute kriegen.
Aber vieles wird auch random sein.
Ja siehste,
da hast du die Antwort von jemandem,
der ein bisschen weiß, wovon er redet,
im Gegensatz zu mir.
Das macht natürlich auch Sinn,
je nachdem, was man eingebaut hat,
zu gucken, stolpert er da überhaupt drüber?
Was bringt das,
wenn du das irgendeinem gibst
und er benutzt das höchstwahrscheinlich nicht?
Ja Twitch und YouTube sind da ja auch,
also Twitch ist da schon länger dabei.
Ich denke halt,
so komplett aussperren
wird halt nur zu weiterem
Wettrennen führen zwischen Adblocker
und der Content-Side.
Auf Twitch ist es doch ähnlich.
Twitch, mal geht Adblocking,
mal geht Adblocking nicht.
Dann brauchst du wieder ein besonderes Add-on
nur für Twitch.
Ich seh, Titan war schon ganz cool,
wo man einfach
Pi-Hole oder sowas installieren konnte.
Da hat es kaum noch Werbung.
Geht ja auch auf vielen Seiten gar nicht mehr richtig
und auf Streamingseiten schon gar nicht.
Am besten war es immer noch auf dem Desktop,
weil du halt richtige Blocker installieren konntest,
die halt auf den Content der Seite zugreifen.
Das ist ja der grundsätzliche Unterschied
zwischen sowas wie Pi-Hole,
die als DNS-Blocker
und Browser-Add-ons.
Browser-Add-ons können halt
den Content der Seite analysieren und sperren,
was immer besser funktioniert,
als einfach nur DNS-Namen zu blocken.
DNS-Namen blocken
beziehungsweise DNS-Auflösung blocken
funktioniert gar nicht,
wenn der Content, den man sehen will
und die Werbung vom gleichen Server ausgeliefert werden,
wie es Twitch jetzt macht.
Das ist halt so ein Wettrennen.
Das ist ja so ein Wettrennen
zwischen Adblockern und Ad-Anbietern.
Das nimmt dann,
aber die Sache ist halt die,
wenn es irgendwann zu krasse Ausmaße annimmt,
auch dass die ganzen Sponsorings auf YouTube,
da gibt es dann solche Sachen wie Sponsor-Block
und sowas.
Die Leute suchen sich immer so ein bisschen was drumherum
und es ist seit Jahren ja schon ein Wettrennen
zwischen
wie kriegt man Werbung rein
und wie kriegt man Werbung raus.
Hast du dir das in Indien geholt oder wo?
Also ich habe ja auch YouTube-Premium.
Ich könnte mir YouTube ohne Premium
auch nicht mehr geben.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gemerkt
und ich habe auch gesehen,
dass manche Streaming-Seiten
mittlerweile selbstverständlich nur
ganz
nur Streaming-Seiten mit Linux-Distribution
dass manche Streaming-Seiten sogar checken,
wenn du die
Developer-Tools vom Browser aufmachst
und dann nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ich wüsste gerne, wie die das checken.
Wahrscheinlich anhand der Größenänderungen
der Elemente auf der Seite oder so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man das wirklich mitbekommt.
Gibt es sowas im JavaScript-Umfeld?
Zumindest habe ich schon gesehen,
dass manche Streaming-Seiten
dann nicht mehr funktionieren,
weil die wollen halt nicht ihre URLs,
wo die Streams herkommen, leaken.
So, ich wollte mal kurz hier fertig gucken.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
AI, AI, AI, okay, nix.
So, dann noch mal schnell hier drüber schauen.
Was gibt es denn?
Okay, Leute, die Rust-Taskforce.
Was ist in dieser Woche in Rust
Geiles passiert?
Space Drive.
Moment, es gibt einen File Explorer
und einen File Explorer.
Rust, also eins muss ich dir echt sagen.
Wisst ihr, was mich in Rust ein bisschen nervt?
Wobei Nerven das falsche Wort ist,
weil letztendlich soll ja jeder
mit seiner Freizeit entwickeln, was er will.
Aber was ich etwas befremdlich finde,
ein Riesentrend in Rust ist es,
Sachen nachzubauen,
die, sag mal, perfectly fine schon funktionieren.
Beispielsweise auch diese ganzen
Command-Line-Tools in Rust.
Ein neues CAT in Rust und sowas.
Ja, okay.
Es gibt einmal hier einen neuen File Explorer
und einmal hier einen neuen File Explorer in Rust.
Okay, top.
Die sind dann blazingly fast.
Ich glaube, ich hatte bei CAT noch nie
irgendwie den Gedanken,
oh, fuck, CAT ist zu langsam beim Ausgeben der Datei.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es in Benchmarks gesehen
tatsächlich LARM versus die Rust-Alternative.
Aber CAT ist halt schlicht und ergreifend
überall drauf.
Und das finde ich halt ein bisschen doof,
wenn man für Standard-Tools,
die man so daily benutzt,
irgendwelche extra Rust-Dinger verwendet,
weil dann gewöhnt man sich im Zweifelsfall
noch an irgendwelche Rust-Features
und du loggst dich per SSH auf dem Server ein,
probierst es aus und es geht nicht.
Es gibt Tools, die sind wirklich sehr nice.
Ja, FZF zum Beispiel,
wobei das nicht Rust-programmiert ist.
Aber das brauche ich auf dem Server nicht.
Das ist lokal zum Suchen cool, ja.
Oder auch mal ein schnelleres Grab,
aber es ist auch sinnvoll.
Aber wichtig ist,
dass man immer noch die Option von Grab kann.
Weil auf irgendwelchen Systemen,
wo du dich remote einloggst,
dann ist halt das Zeug nicht drauf.
Da ist halt Standard-Linux-Tools drauf und fertig.
Rust, C++ oder Javascript?
Warum nicht eine gescheite Sprache?
Sieht hässlich als fuck aus.
Ach, das ist für irgendwelche
Embedded
Guides-Sachen, okay.
Aber UI-Frameworks sind schwierig.
Was ist eine gescheite Sprache?
Kommt immer drauf an, was du machen willst.
Ansonsten, wenn du nicht weißt,
was du machen willst,
wenn du einfach ein bisschen
dich da mal rantasten willst ans Programmieren,
dann würde ich sagen
Browser, Editor, Javascript
zum Einstieg.
Ach, wir ärgern uns hier zur Zeit mit Java, warum?
Wie wärs mit Kotlin?
Dann könnt ihr alles weiterverwenden,
was ihr schon gebaut habt
und ansonsten,
ich persönlich bin der Meinung,
C Sharp ist eindeutig angenehm
oder viel angenehmer als Java.
Wenn sie auch einige wirre Sachen
eingebaut haben die letzten Jahre über.
Und ansonsten,
so zum Einstieg,
die üblichen Verdächtigen,
wie gesagt, Javascript, Go, Python,
C Sharp.
Und als fünftes kann man sich sicherlich streiten.
Früher hätte ich gesagt Ruby
als Einstiegssprache,
aber das hat ja komplett
verloren.
So mit dem Abstieg von Rails
als Top Frontend,
also nicht Frontend,
Backend Framework.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit habe ich gesehen,
manche Leute
haben auf ihren Linux-Kisten
noch alte Perl-Sachen laufen.
Da weißt du gleich,
das sind welche, die haben früher
nur Solaris gemacht und sowas.
Letztens gesehen bei uns
im Frontend stand irgendein Perl-Skript.
Das steht da wahrscheinlich
seit 20 Jahren schon drin.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Polkadot Node Implementation,
was ist das überhaupt?
Ah, Blockchain, okay, verstehe.
Polkadot klingt so nach
Cometed Blockchain.
Blockchain, Blockchain.
Also in Rust tut sich einiges.
In Rust tut sich einiges.
Lasst nochmal schnell gucken,
was es in C Sharp Neues gibt.
Hier nochmal schnell
Clean Architecture.
Fast Shit Hub.
T. Dot. Net Runtime.
Dachte, es wird nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt.
Ah, wird es auch nicht.
Warum trendet das,
wenn es nicht weiterentwickelt wird?
What the fuck? Hä?
Warum? Wo ist der Sinn?
Wird es vielleicht doch
irgendwie weiterentwickelt?
Elasticsearch.
Moin CMDR Big M.
Alles klar.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wie wäre es mit Kotlin?
Wie gesagt, dann habt ihr was,
was gescheit funktioniert
und alles benutzt werden kann,
was jetzt schon da ist.
Und Kotlin hat schon eine große Zukunft,
gehe ich zumindest von aus.
Exzellent, so muss das sein.
High IQ Time ist angebrochen, Chat.
Ja, habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Irgendjemand hat was mit Rapper
oder so gefragt vorhin.
Wie testet man,
wenn man eine Rapper-Klasse
um eine externe AP geschrieben hat?
Ja, das ist das gleiche Problem,
was ich gerade beschrieben habe.
Wenn du nicht genau weißt,
was die da zurückliefert in allen Fällen
bzw. keine Doku dafür hast,
ist es halt schwierig,
das ordentlich abzufackeln.
Du kannst halt im Prinzip auch nur testen,
wo du weißt,
was so in deiner Hand fliegt.
Ich meine, was du machen kannst,
ist klassischen Tests,
du rufst das mit unterschiedlichen Parametern auf
und guckst, ob es das Richtige macht.
Du kannst auch versuchen,
möglichst viele Fehlerfälle abzufangen,
aber wenn auf einmal
irgendein Feld rausfliegt oder so,
was die externe AP zurückliefert,
diesen ganz besonderen Fall
wirst du halt nicht testen können.
Du kannst halt prinzipiell testen,
entspricht das der Struktur,
die ich erwarte, ja, das geht.
Und in den Fällen werfe ich vielleicht
eine Aussage,
kräftige Exception, so was, das geht,
aber du kannst halt nichts testen,
wo du gar nicht weißt,
was es denn so machen könnte.
Wenn morgen das ein Int anstatt ein String ist,
kannst du nicht heute schon testen,
ob es ein Int ist,
weil du weißt ja nicht,
ob das auch was sein könnte.
Du kannst höchstens testen drauf,
ja, es muss immer ein String sein.
Gibt es die Woche sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber ich habe mir gestern ja schon
Gedanken zugemacht,
ich glaube wirklich,
viel passiert ist die Woche nicht.
Es gab diese Twitter-Geschichte,
es gab, ähm,
ja, was ich auch gelesen habe,
ist, dass der Entwickler hinter
Herr der Ringe Gollum
keinen Bock mehr hat,
Spiele zu entwickeln, verständlicherweise.
Das war ja auch richtiger Schrott, Alter.
Ansonsten,
einfach laufen lassen,
solange sie laufen und nicht anfassen,
wenn es keiner versteht.
Weil wenn es keiner versteht,
es ist auch schwierig,
die Feinheiten in eine andere Programmiersprache
umzudingsen.
Also da ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich besser,
man überlegt sich nochmal,
klar, also grundsätzlich,
was soll das Programm eigentlich machen,
und dann baut man das in Python
und vielleicht, wenn man manchmal nicht genau weiß,
okay, wie ist es jetzt,
guckt man sich mal was ab in Perl,
gar nicht richtig versteht,
das stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Ich würde den Kram einfach laufen lassen,
solange er funktioniert.
Vielleicht gucken,
mal die eigentlichen Anforderungen
da dran zu erfassen
und dann was Neues zu bauen in Python.
Vielleicht, weil es kann durchaus sein,
wenn die Skripte 20 Jahre alt sind,
dass vieles davon gar nicht mehr gebraucht wird
und es allein schon deswegen keinen Sinn macht,
das 1 zu 1 umzubauen.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Zeigt mal her,
die beste Battlefield seit Jahren.
Oh, das gucken wir mal,
gucken wir mal, was die GameStar dazu sagt.
Meine Meinung, so ein bisschen kennt ihr ja schon.
Ich habe die Playtests gespielt,
ich habe auch das Early Access mir mittlerweile gekauft.
Also, auch wenn ich Pixelgrafik mag,
ich fand diese Pixelgrafik zu detailarm
und auch die Maps zu detailarm
und auch,
das Game hat auch keine richtige Belichtung,
die gescheit, also,
schon die Belichtung funktioniert,
aber die Grafik sieht nicht gut aus.
Das ist, glaube ich, echt ein Spiel,
was von sowas wie Raytracing ultra profitieren könnte.
Optisch.
Ja, Schatten, genau,
sowas in der Richtung, das meine ich, ja.
Schauen wir mal, was die GameStar dazu sagt.
Gebäude sind Boden und Wänden in der Kleidung.
Ja, ja, genau, genau das,
Chat, genau das trifft es, ja.
Genau, genau das meine ich.
Und dazu kommt halt,
dass die Maps extrem detailarm sind.
Also, du hast,
du hast Häuser,
die unlogisch miteinander verbunden sind
und du hast, das steht nirgendwo,
nichts irgendwo, nichts,
in keinem Tunnel steht nichts, einfach leer.
Ja.
Okay, gucken wir uns doch mal an,
was die GameStar dazu sagt.
Bin gespannt.
Mal kurz gucken, dass die Lautstärke stimmt.
Seit über einer Woche hält sich
der Multiplayer-Shooter BattleBit Remastered
an der Spitze der ...
Lass mal kurz gucken,
Steam Stats BattleBit,
das will ich gar nicht.
Ah nee, jetzt heißt es ja nicht mehr Charts,
heißt es ja mittlerweile.
Ja, nicht übel.
Ich mein, wir wissen alle,
dass es relativ schnell wieder runtergehen wird,
aber nicht, nicht verkehrt.
Du weißt oftmals nicht, von wo du stirbst, ja.
Ja.
Der Verkaufschatz von Steam.
Das neue Spiel ...
Guck hier, das ist halt,
du hast halt keine Beleuchtung,
das ist das, was ich meine.
Es gibt keine Beleuchtung in dem Game so richtig.
Das ist halt nicht der Stil.
Es ist so dieses, guck mal,
im Haus sieht halt aus wie außen am Haus und sowas.
Das ist so ...
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie das richtige Wort heißt.
Es ist nicht der Stil,
es ist nicht der Grafikstil an sich,
dass es pixellig ist,
aber ich würd's halt mal als Zusammenfassung,
die Beleuchtung ist halt Müll.
Minimap stimmt, aber gut, ich mein,
also die M-Comps,
die Flaggen verschwinden auch so komisch,
wenn man in die Richtung guckt und so.
Ja.
Das Spiel wurde in den letzten Tagen
oft als das bessere Battlefield gelobt
und für seine eindrucksvollen Spielerzahlen bestaunt.
In der Spitze waren über 80.000 virtuelle Soldaten
zur gleichen Zeit auf den Schlachtfelden.
Okay, mal gucken, was die Gamester sagen.
Bis zu 254 davon sogar in einer Partie.
Dabei sieht Battle Bit
mit seinen knapp texturierten Landschaften und Gebäuden
und mit den grobschlechtig ausmodellierten Spielfiguren
und Fahrzeugen eher nach einer Mischung
zwischen Minecraft und Roblox aus.
Nicht unbedingt die Art von Grafik,
die man bei einem Battlefield-Konkurrenten erwarten würde.
Doch die Optik ist erstaunlich stimmig
und, was noch viel wichtiger ist ...
Ich finde nicht, dass die Optik stimmig ist.
Wie gesagt, mir gefällt die Optik nicht.
Die inneren Werte von Battle Bit Remastered
können auch überzeugen, besonders zum günstigen ...
Nachts sieht das tatsächlich besser aus wie tagsüber, ne?
Seht ihr mal, was so ein bisschen da was an Beleuchtung ausmacht.
... Preis von gerade mal 15 Euro.
Die Einstiegshürde in die Early Access ...
Das sieht halt einfach ...
Das sieht halt einfach so ...
So platt irgendwie aus, so.
... Version des Ego-Shooters ist also denkbar gering
und die Begeisterung auf Steam entsprechend groß.
Von mehr als 20.000 User-Reviews fallen 90 Prozent positiv aus.
Die Spieler loben es als das ...
... beste Battlefield seit Jahren
und so immersiv, dass dein Gehirn die Roblox-Grafik für dich verbessert.
Tatsächlich wirkt Battle Bit, bis auf die Grafik,
wie ein weiterer Teil der Battlefield-Reihe.
Auf großen Maps kämpfen zwei Teams in bekannten Modi
wie Conquest oder Rush um Flaggenpunkte.
Dabei spielen sie verschiedene Klassen,
die alle ihre eigenen Waffen und Gadgets besitzen.
Der Assault spezialisiert sich auf den Infanteriekampf,
der Medic kann seine Teammitglieder schneller wiederbeleben
und ist auch der Einzige,
der sich selbst und andere komplett heilen kann.
Ja, wenn man checkt, mit welcher Taste man das Ganze macht ...
Ich hab lange gebraucht, bis ich gecheckt habe,
welche Taste ich drücken muss zum Heilen.
Das steht natürlich auch nirgendwo auf dem UI da, ne?
Oh, doch, doch! Mittlerweile steht es da.
Rechte Maustaste heilt andere. Tatsächlich.
Ähm, nee. Nee, das ist ...
Nee, doch, doch. Ich glaub, das ist richtig.
Oder auch der Health-Indikator, der ist neu.
Den gab's auch beim letzten Playtest noch nicht.
Ja, das ist neu. Das stand das letzte Mal noch nicht da.
... ist der beste für und gegen alle Arten von Fahrzeugen.
Der Support schießt mit LMGs um sich
und versorgt sein Team mit Munition.
Und die Recon-Klasse ist der klassische Scharfschütze.
Zuletzt gibt's dann noch den Teamleader,
der Assault- und Marksman-Rifles mitnimmt
und über einen separaten Voice-Chat-Kanal
mit anderen Squadleadern verbunden ist,
um sich zu koordinieren.
Die über 15 Maps, die schon im Spiel sind,
bieten eine Menge Abwechslung.
Und der Pool wird rasch erweitert.
Die erste neue Karte kam seit dem Early Access.
Das ist halt auch der Vorteil.
Solche Maps sind halt, sagen wir mal,
schneller zu erstellen als super detailreiche Maps.
Es hat schon seinen Vorteil,
das im minimalistischen Grafikstil zu machen.
Early Access starrt schon dazu.
Gegämpft wird in Städten, Wüsten ...
Es ist auf jeden Fall langsamer als Battlefield.
Und du stirbst halt random durch Sachen,
wo du nicht siehst.
Aber ja.
Es ist tatsächlich realistischer angehaucht,
auch wenn es nicht so aussieht,
als wie Battlefield.
... oder Wäldern.
Am Ende der Runde kann dich sogar gleich noch die Karte bewerten.
Battlefield V ist im Angebot.
Ja.
Wenn du keinen Bock auf 2042 hast,
was ich verstehen kann, warum nicht?
Spielerzahlen sind trotzdem gut.
Ich glaube, Spielerzahlen sind in 5 und 1
glaube ich noch höher als bei 2042.
... Entwicklern so ein bisschen direktes Feedback geben.
Coole Sache, besonders für eine Early Access-Version.
Wie so vielen anderen Spielern
fiel mir die simple Grafik nach ein paar Runden übrigens auch.
Der eine Entwickler spielt Battlefield
und der andere Squad.
Okay, das erklärt es.
Das ist natürlich die Erklärung.
Genauso fühlt es sich nämlich an.
Ja, wenn man das weiß,
genau so fühlt es sich an.
Ja.
... nicht mehr auf.
Zumal die Low-Poly-Optik
noch einen ganz entscheidenden Vorteil hat.
Battle Bit Remastered läuft auf jeder Möhre.
Zusammen mit dem schlappen Preis von 15 Euro,
also gerade mal 5 Euro mehr
als die meisten Battle-Passes heutzutage,
ist die Einstiegshürde, wie schon gesagt, sehr gering.
Ob und wann Battle Bit aber für andere Plattformen erscheint,
ist noch nicht klar.
Der Preis soll sich am PC aber vorerst nicht ändern,
wobei sich die Entwickler durchaus noch eine kleine Hintertür
für Preisanpassungen offen lassen.
Der große Erfolg und die Begeisterung für Battle Bit ...
Ja, lass mal abwarten in 2, 3 Wochen.
Ich denke, die Spielerzahlen werden schon drastisch droppen wieder.
Aber es wäre wünschenswert,
dass man das konstant spielen kann.
... Remastered,
lassen sich aber nicht nur auf Preis, Hardwareanforderungen
und Umfang des Spiels zurückführen.
Viel wichtiger ist am Ende natürlich das Gameplay.
Und das ist, kein Witz, stellenweise wesentlich taktischer
als das große Vorbild Battlefield.
Ja, ist so, hat er recht.
Das war für mich auch eine der größten Überraschungen des Spiels,
denn damit hatte ich tatsächlich so gar nicht gerechnet.
Battle Bit sieht zwar nach Arcade-Action aus,
bietet aber jede Menge Tiefgang.
Das geht schon beim Nachladen los.
Statt einem allgemeinen Kugelvorrat
trage ich tatsächlich einzelne Magazine mit mir.
Hat ein bisschen was von Wake Island Light.
Darum, wenn ich eines davon nicht ganz leer schieße,
kann ich es später wieder verwenden.
Um schneller nachzuladen,
kann ich ein Magazin auch auf den Boden fallen lassen.
Falls ich später noch Zeit habe, hebe ich es einfach wieder auf.
Die Trefferpunkte funktionieren auch anders,
als man es aus modernen Shootern gewohnt ist.
Nehme ich genug Schaden,
muss ich mich erst mal ganz schnell mit Bandagen versorgen
und die Blutung stoppen.
Danach bin ich aber erst wieder bei etwa einem Drittel
meiner vollen Gesundheit.
Um komplett zu heilen, muss ich einen Medik aufsuchen.
Beiße ich doch mal komplett ins Gras,
ist aber noch nicht alles vorbei.
Meine Teamkollegen haben jetzt die Chance, mich wiederzubeleben.
Anders als im aktuellen Battlefield,
kann das grundsätzlich jedes Teammitglied.
Der Medik macht es nur etwas schneller.
Liege ich dabei in einer ungünstigen Position,
ziehen meine Teamkollegen mich aus dem Weg
und hinter eine sichere Deckung.
Das geht übrigens auch mit dem Gegnerteam,
was zu wirklich lustigen Situationen im Voice-Chat führen kann.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Der Sprach-Chat erinnert mich immer wieder an den aus Hell Let Loose.
Über drei verschiedene Kanäle
rede ich entweder mit den Leuten in meiner Nähe,
mit meinem Squad,
oder spreche mich mit weiteren Squadleadern ab,
wenn ich selber einer bin.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich den Voice-Chat nutze,
hören das alle umliegenden Spieler.
Auch das Gegnerteam.
Sogar nach dem Tod nutze ich den Chat
um nach Hilfe zu schreien
oder meinen Teamkollegen Tipps zu geben,
von wo ich getötet wurde.
Aber wie gesagt, das hört dann auch der Gegner.
In meinen bisherigen Matches
wurde der Chat aber weniger für taktische Absprachen
und mehr für Witze und Chaos genutzt.
Sehr froh war ich, als ich gemerkt habe,
dass die meisten Leute dabei einfach freundlich bleiben.
Klar, man ärgert die Gegner und fordert sie heraus,
aber es bleibt freundschaftlich
und ernsthafte Beleidigungen sind nach meiner bisherigen Erfahrung
Ja, Beleidigungen fangen erst so richtig krass an,
sollte es mal einen Rank-Modus geben oder sowas,
wovon ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ausgehe.
Ich glaube, das macht da wenig Sinn.
zum Glück die Ausnahme.
Dann werden die Leute immer richtig toxic.
Es kommt eine wirkliche Verbundenheit mit dem eigenen Team auf,
wenn man sich Sprüche zuruft und zusammenarbeitet.
Ich hatte zwar noch nicht...
Guck mal, wie viel besser das mit ein bisschen Beleuchtung aussieht,
nachts als tagsüber.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
...mit Freunden über Discord zu spielen,
aber von dem, was man online sieht...
Guck mal, ohne Scheiß, das sieht einfach nur platt und billig aus.
Und das sieht einfach viel, viel besser aus,
mit Schatten und unterschiedlicher Beleuchtung.
Ich hatte zwar noch nicht die Chance,
mit Freunden über Discord zu spielen,
aber von dem, was man online sieht,
haben die Leute eine Menge Spaß,
gemeinsam im Panzer oder Helikopter zu sitzen
und sich abzusprechen.
Die Menge an verfügbaren Waffen in Battle.Bit Remastered
hat mich auch überrascht.
Es gibt jede Menge Pistolen, Sturm- und Scharfschützengewehr...
Ja, und die kannst du customisen,
inklusive du kannst sogar deinen Soldat customisen
mit Bodyarmor und sowas.
Eigentlich schon ziemlich durchdacht.
...die alle etliche Aufsätze zum Freischalten haben.
Neue Aufsätze schalte ich durch Kills
mit der jeweiligen Waffe frei.
An meinem Scharfschützengewehr
habe ich mittlerweile drei unterschiedliche Visiere,
eine Taschenlampe und schalte später noch
einen Distanzsucher frei.
Einige nennen das vielleicht Overkill.
Ich sage, ich bin gut vorbereitet.
Ausrüstung erhalte ich, wenn ich im Rang aufsteige.
Hier gibt es nur...
Das haben sie ja auch angekündigt,
dass Battlefield Friends zu 2042 zurück ist.
Und es gab irgendwie drei Folgen oder so
und dann hatte der keinen Bock mehr, verständlicherweise.
...einen allgemeinen Soldatenrang
und keine klassenspezifischen Level.
Auch wenn ich also nur Engineer spiele,
schalte ich nach und nach trotzdem
neue Waffen für Medic, Recon und Co. frei.
Falls ich dann keine Lust mehr auf Engineer habe,
habe ich trotzdem eine breite Auswahl,
wenn ich zum Support rüber wechsle.
Auch meinen Soldaten passe ich so an,
wie es mir gefällt.
Klar, ob das jetzt grüne oder braune Pixelaugen sind,
ist relativ egal.
Bei der Ausrüstung handelt es sich aber tatsächlich um...
Ja, du kannst Bodyarmor und so Zeug aus,
finde ich eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt.
...dische Entscheidungen.
Nehme ich einen anderen Rucksack mit,
renne ich zwar schneller,
kann dafür aber nicht so viele meiner Gadgets mitnehmen.
Hier verbergen sich zwar keine unendlichen Bildoptionen,
aber es ist schon mal mehr als das,
was mir Battlefield in Sachen Anpassbarkeit bietet.
Im laufenden Spiel kann ich mich dann vorsichtig
aus der Deckung herauslehnen,
hinknien und hinlegen
und fast jedes Gebäude auf der Karte tatsächlich betreten.
Meistens haben die Häuser auch mehrere Stockwerke und...
Ja, die Gebäude sind aber ziemlich unsinnig verbunden miteinander.
Also man denkt oft mal so,
ah, da gehe ich jetzt rein,
Gegner ist hier an dem Fenster,
ich gehe jetzt da unten durch die Tür
und da geht es dann irgendwie nicht durch.
Das ist einfach so wild,
weil du meistens ja die Wände zerstören kannst.
Überall können Feuergefechte ausbrechen,
denn auf den großen Karten ist bei voller Besetzung viel los.
Guck, aber ich meine, okay,
hier ist ja zwar wenigstens so eine Art Küche im Haus,
aber sonst sind die Gebäude an vielen Stellen einfach komplett leer.
Da ist einfach gar nichts.
Das sind einfach nur graue, braune Blöcke.
Bis zu 254 Spieler
kämpfen in den Multiplayer-Partien von Battle.bit Remastered.
Ich kann aber auch in Matches mit 128 oder nur 64 Spielern einsteigen.
Apropos einsteigen,
ich starte nicht nur in meiner Basis bei eroberten Flaggenpunkten
oder bei Squadmitgliedern in eine laufende Runde hinein,
sondern auch bei mobilen Spawnpunkten,
vorausgesetzt mein Squadleader hat so eine Funkanlage hier aufgebaut.
Jeder Spieler kann zusätzlich
noch kleine Schutzmauern aus Sandsäcken aufstellen.
Die sind aber keineswegs permanent,
denn so gut wie jedes Gebäude in Battle.bit Remastered ist zerstörbar.
Mit Hämmern, C4 und Panzerfäusten reiße ich Wände ein
und mit genug Beschuss brechen ganze Gebäude in sich zusammen.
Bis auf die Landschaft ist keine Deckung.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch nicht gesehen, bisher einstürzende Gebäude.
Wirklich permanent.
Ein ausgefalleneres Gadget ist der Enterhaken,
der mir aus Battlefield 2042 bekannt vorkommt.
Der zieht mich aber nicht direkt zum Ankerpunkt,
sondern hängt dort ein für alle Spieler nutzbares Seil hin.
Das ist zwar nicht so schnell,
dafür kann mein Squad aber mit mir kommen.
Besonders kreative Spieler nutzen aktuell ihre Drohnen,
um Antipersonenminen mitten in die feindlichen Stellungen zu fliegen.
Das erinnert mich an die guten alten Zeiten des C4-Bugs in Battlefield.
In Battle.bit Remastered steckt also schon ganz schön viel drin.
Und dabei hat die Early-Access-Phase gerade erst begonnen.
Allerdings arbeitet das winzige Entwicklerteam
auch schon seit rund sieben Jahren an dem Titel
und hat in dieser Zeit das Spiel immer wieder neu erfunden.
Da kommt übrigens auch das Remastered im Titel her.
Es gab nämlich nie ein Original-Battle.bit.
Zumindest keines, das die Öffentlichkeit kaufen oder spielen konnte.
Doch was die entwickelten ...
Aber Remastered klingt einfach in der heutigen Zeit viel cooler.
Was wir jetzt auf Steam veröffentlicht haben,
ist besonders für ein Early-Access-Spiel
in einem erstaunlich robusten Zustand.
Mir sind kaum gravierende Bugs aufgefallen
und auch der allgemeine Spielablauf funktioniert schon sehr gut.
Im Detail gibt es natürlich Verbesserungsmöglichkeiten.
Die Waffensounds müssten ...
Also gerade das Klettern und so,
das fühlt sich schon noch sehr durch Schienen,
also wie auf Schienen an.
Beispielsweise noch mal überarbeitet werden.
Ich erwarte hier keine realistischen Aufnahmen,
aber mein Gewehr sollte dann doch etwas wuchtiger klingen.
Außerdem fehlen noch etliche andere Sounds
um die Spielkulisse hinzukommen.
Ein bisschen Musik in den Menüs könnte auch nicht schaden.
Überhaupt ist die Benutzeroberfläche noch etwas rudimentär.
Im Hauptmenü ...
Ohne Scheiß, ich finde das Menü eingängiger
als das von Battlefield 2042.
Man erkennt zwar auch,
dass es eigentlich irgendein Webbrowser ist, das Menü,
also höchstwahrscheinlich,
aber ich meine, man findet irgendwie sich besser zurecht.
Im Menü vermisse ich ganz besonders die Option,
auch außerhalb der Matches,
meine Klassen und Loadouts anzupassen.
Eine generelle Übersicht über die Freischaltungen
auf den nächsten Leveln fehlt auch noch.
Das Heads-Up-Display verträgt ebenfalls noch etwas Feinschliff.
Ich muss wirklich nicht permanent
jedes einzelne meiner Teammitglieder eingeblendet haben,
die quer über die Map verstreut sind.
Das stört mehr,
als dass es tatsächlich hilfreiche Informationen liefert.
Aber das sind alles Sachen,
die in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten und Jahren kommen könnten,
denn Battle Bit Remastered soll wohl noch grob zwei Jahre lang
im Early Access bleiben.
Vielleicht ist das sogar genug Zeit ...
Ich hoffe, Sie verlieren nicht den Spaß daran,
weil jetzt ist halt das Ding,
jetzt wo die Leute Geld dafür ausgegeben haben,
und sei es nur 15 Euro,
fangen sie an zu nerven,
wenn ihnen irgendwas nicht gefällt.
Ja?
Also ...
Und so eine Game-Community
kann der größte Abfuck überhaupt sein
und die Leute dazu bringen,
keinen Bock mehr zu haben,
das Game weiterzuentwickeln.
... und allgemein veränderte Sichtkonditionen
wären eine spannende Ergänzung
zu den Tag- und Nachtvarianten der Karten.
Bis zum 1.0-Release
wollen die Entwickler jedenfalls Fehler beheben,
neue Features einbauen und vor allem ...
Guck!
Hier sieht man eigentlich ganz gut,
was mir an der Grafik nicht gefällt.
Du hast keine Schatten richtig,
du hast keine richtige Beleuchtung.
Es sieht halt alles sehr platt und detailarm aus.
Und das liegt nicht daran,
dass es Pixel-Grafiken gibt,
sondern weil es einfach keine Details hat.
Da steht nichts rum.
Das sind einfach nur verschiedene farbige ...
Das hat ja nicht mal richtige Texturen.
Das ist einfach nur ein einfarbiger Block.
Mehrere einfarbige Blocks aneinandergereiht.
... vor allem das Spiel anhand des Feedbacks
der Spieler verfeinern.
Das klingt zwar etwas vage,
aber wenn man sich die Schlagzeilen ...
Ich muss jetzt was Böses sagen.
Und wenn man sich die Schlagzeilen ...
Mein PP-Game letztens war auch nicht mehr feierlich.
... das Feedback der Spieler verfeinern.
Aber ich möchte einfach mal sagen,
Gaming-Journalist-Aim-Mode aktiviert.
Aber wenn man sich die Schlagzahl der Updates
in den letzten Tagen anschaut ...
Nicht, dass ich es besser hinbekommen hätte.
... sollten allein die nächsten Wochen
schon sehr spannend werden.
Zumal bereits neue Fahrzeuge, Spielmodi, Gadgets,
Maps und Waffen bestätigt sind.
Außerdem soll es einen Militär-Simulationsmodus geben,
der das Teamspiel noch mehr in den Mittelpunkt stellt.
Oh, noch mehr.
Der neue Battle-Bit wird damit
auch ein bisschen in Richtung Squad oder Arma gehen.
Ob das Spiel dadurch zum Dauerbrenner wird
oder doch eher eine der vielen Eintagsfliegen auf Steam bleibt,
kann ich noch nicht abschätzen.
Die Grundlagen für eine lange Erfolgsgeschichte
sind aber gelegt.
Das Gunplay macht Spaß
und die Waffen spielen sich wirklich unterschiedlich.
Das Teamplay wird durch die Stärken und Schwächen
der einzelnen Klassen gefördert.
Ich glaube, wir spielen heute Abend auch noch mal ein paar Runden.
... sind kreativ gestaltet und verändern sich während eines Matches.
Habt ihr das Game-Chat?
Ich mache einfach mal Squad auf heute Abend.
Refunded?
Okay, mal gucken.
Permanent.
Battle-Bit bietet jetzt schon genug Content,
um lange bei der Stange zu halten
und liefert eine Battlefield-Erfahrung,
die ich seit dem vierten Serienteil nicht mehr hatte.
Es ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür,
dass mit dem richtigen Ansatz
auch ein Indie-Spiel die Massen erobern kann
und selbst Platzhirsche wie Battlefield in den Schatten stellt.
Vor ein paar Wochen
habe ich ein Video zu World War 3 gemacht.
Dort hatte ich auch gesagt,
dass ich mich an die Stärken von Battlefield 3 erinnere.
Ja, das, was mich da ein bisschen nervt, ist Mail.ru-Anticheat.
... drei und vier erinnert.
Mein größter Kritikpunkt war damals,
dass World War 3 sehr viele gute Ideen hat,
aber keine davon bis zum Ende durchzieht.
Bei Battle-Bit Remastered sieht es zum Glück anders aus.
Der neue Steam-Hit ist nicht vollgestopft
mit unvollendeten Features.
Stattdessen konzentriert sich Battle-Bit
auf eine simple, aber taktisch durchaus anspruchsvolle Spielerfahrung
und funktioniert wahrscheinlich genau deshalb,
dass Battle-Bit jetzt schon so gut.
Die vergleichsweise einfache Grafik
unterstützt den klaren Designansatz sogar noch mehr
und sorgt für Übersicht und gute Spielbarkeit.
Vielleicht sollten auch die Battlefield-Entwickler
für ihren nächsten...
Wisst ihr, ich glaube, das ist echt ein Game,
was mega von Raytracing-Beleuchtung profitieren könnte.
... Serienteil ein paar Runden Battle-Bit spielen
und sich auf den Kern ihrer Marke besinnen.
Denn so sehr Battle-Bit...
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Wie gesagt, der größte Battlefield-Killer
ist nicht irgendein anderes Battlefield-artiges Game,
sondern DICE selbst.
Auch wenn Battlefield inspiriert sein mag,
es geht bestimmt auch andersrum.
Naja...
Pog!
Ja, wird mal Zeit.
Muss man...
Müssen wir überhaupt mal ran heute Abend.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon eine Weile gespielt.
Auch die ganzen Playtests und sowas.
World War 3 ist jetzt auch free-to-play.
Wir haben es jetzt endlich hingekriegt, ja.
Mal gucken, was haben wir denn hier?
Office jetzt kostenlos.
Ist das so?
Guck mal hier, das ist das Skript für diesen Beitrag
und ich tippe das hier nicht in ein lokal installiertes
Microsoft Word auf meinem Rechner,
sondern in Microsoft Word in meinem Browser.
Ja, okay.
Ist das kostenlos jetzt?
Kann ich mein Office 365,
Microsoft 365 Abo wieder kündigen, ja?
Wie gesagt, ich bin eh da.
Ihr kennt mich.
Ihr wisst, dass ich ungern Office-Zeug benutze.
Ja, wusstet ihr vielleicht schon,
Microsoft bietet sein Office-Paket im Browser
seit einiger Zeit gratis an.
Und einige sagen sogar,
dass das klassische Office
mit lokal installierten Programmen tot sei.
Naja, ich habe es auch am Start.
Aber Browser geht genauso gut.
Kennst du eigentlich Duty Calls?
Klar.
Wisst ihr eigentlich,
dass das ganze Office auf React basiert?
Also, die ganze Online-Browser-Office-Geschichte
dass es React-based ist.
Also, Microsoft hat mal nichts Eigenes gebastelt,
sondern hat was Gescheites benutzt,
auch wenn es von Facebook ist.
Das ist alles React-basiert.
Schauen wir uns das mal genauer an,
ob das wirklich so stimmt.
Und vor allem vergleichen wir
Microsofts Browser-Office
mit der Konkurrenz von Google und Apple.
Für wen eignet sich was am besten
und wo sind so die Grenzen im Browser-Office?
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Eckerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
NordVPN.
Ah, nee.
Inkognito.
Ja, sicher.
Im Büro dürften viele von euch
eh einfach Microsoft Office
auf dem Rechner installiert haben.
Leider.
Ja, habe ich.
Unhetzliches Outlook, Alter.
Was übrigens glaube ich auch
demnächst irgendwie abgelöst werden soll.
Laut dieser Studie hier.
1983 ist übrigens die erste Version
von Word erschienen.
So hat das damals ausgesehen
und es war mehr so ein
What you see is what you get.
Einfach in Echtzeit Text eingeben
und verarbeiten.
Das war damals eine tolle Sache.
Ja, seitdem ist auch viel passiert.
Das Internet zum Beispiel und...
Man darf nicht vergessen,
ich meine, wie war das?
Office 97?
Das habe ich bestimmt 10 Jahre lang
in Office 97 oder so benutzt.
Ja.
Und danach eigentlich so gut
wie kein Office mehr,
weil ich immer noch der Meinung bin,
dass eigentlich das alles
total overrated ist.
Also das einzige Programm
im ganzen Office,
was wirklich eine
Daseinsberechtigung hat,
finde ich, ist Excel.
Excel ist so die Idee der Sekretärin
beziehungsweise die Idee des
Projektmanagers oder so,
aber den Rest,
eigentlich brauchst du den Rest nicht.
PowerPoint eventuell noch,
wenn du verpflichtet bist,
Präsentationen im Corporate Design
zu erstellen, das gibt halt nur
PowerPoint Vorlagen.
Google ist auch passiert
und damit hat sich natürlich auch viel
im Bereich...
Ja gut, Lotus Notes ist wirklich
kompletter Abfuck.
Das stimmt.
Im Vergleich zu Lotus Notes
ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich
viele Dokumente und Tabellen getan.
Microsoft hat mittlerweile
sein Office Suite unter dem Namen
Microsoft 365 Online zur Verfügung
gestellt und das Ganze auch ohne
kostenpflichtiges Abo.
Also etwas eingeschränktes Word,
Excel...
Welche Office Tools verwendest du?
Naja, wie gesagt, ich habe ein Abo
für Microsoft 365,
aber ich verwende eigentlich,
wenn sie es vermeiden,
gar keine Office Tools.
Ich nehme einen Texteditor
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo du ein bisschen advancere
Formatierung des Dokuments brauchst,
aber ich brauche meistens,
also nie eigentlich,
advance Formatierung des Dokuments.
Mir reicht es, wenn ich die
Überschrift fett machen kann,
einen Codeblock einfügen kann,
meinen Text fett und so.
Genug, ja.
Also ich komme zu 95% mit
einem Markdown Dokument aus.
Den anderen Kram aus Office brauche
ich nicht, Excel brauche ich auch
nicht, PowerPoint.
Benutzt du die 1TB Speicher
von OneDrive?
Ja, das ist eines der Gründe,
warum ich tatsächlich mich
dazu durchgerungen habe,
mir ein Microsoft 365 Abo zu
kaufen, weil ich die Kombination
aus Office plus ordentlich
OneDrive Speicher ganz praktisch
finde.
PowerPoint für alle,
die ein Microsoft Account haben.
Der Name Office wird langfristig
durch Microsoft 365 ersetzt.
Tod ist das Konzept,
Word, Excel oder PowerPoint ganz
normal offline zu verwenden,
also noch nicht.
Die Namen, also Word, Excel,
PowerPoint bleiben auch erhalten,
nur eben Office nicht.
Apple bietet seine Office-Programme
unter dem Namen iWork ja schon
seit 2005 für Macs an und seit
10 Jahren kann man das auch
online im Browser nutzen.
Ja und Google hat 2009 unter dem
Namen Wave ein Online-Tool
vorgestellt.
Achso, ja das ist das,
was in Google Docs dann
aufging später.
Dafür gesorgt hat, dass mehrere
Leute gleichzeitig an einem
Textdokument arbeiten konnten,
ohne dass es zu Problemen mit
dem Speichern kam und auf einmal
unterschiedliche Versionen der
gleichen Datei da waren.
Dieses Feature wurde später auch
in andere Google-Dienste integriert,
Docs und Tabellen kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich. Ja und die
gemeinsamen Bearbeiten-Funktionen
sind eigentlich schon wieder
genuscht, doch für ein eigenes
Video, denn es gab langen Hin und
Her, wie Microsoft mit Office auch
in Bezug auf Smartphones und
Tablets Geld verdienen kann.
Da gab es dann 2015 zum Beispiel
mal die Regel, das Office gratis
auf Geräten bis 10,1 Zoll zu
verwenden.
Ja, was auch immer Microsoft sich
da wieder gedacht hat.
10,2 Zoll.
Microsoft hat sich später
entschlossen, dieses abgespeckte
Online-Dienst zu verstehen.
Das hat sicherlich auch mit der
Popularität von Google Docs und
Ich meine, für uns ist das gut.
Da kann man nämlich Office auch
ordentlich unter Linux verwenden.
Da muss man mit so einem Krempel
wie LibreOffice und so gar nicht
anfangen. Es ist halt in der
Businesswelt so, dass die meisten
Sachen irgendwie auf Microsoft
Office Zeug aufsetzen. Gut, wenn
es selbstprogrammierte Makros und
so ein Shit gibt, ja, dann hast
du Pech.
Das hält allerdings auch so ein
bisschen das letzte wirklich gute
Argument gegen Linux oder Mac OS
oder Chrome OS oder sonst was,
weil, wie schon gesagt, Office ist
Industriestandard und für viele
eben total wichtig beim Arbeiten.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt einfach im
Browser online verwenden kann,
brauche ich nicht mehr zwingend
Windows, sondern kann auch irgendein
anderes Betrieb.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Noch ist das nicht so weit.
Die Desktop-Versionen haben schon
einiges zu tun. Wer sich dafür
entscheidet, im Browser Online Text
in Word oder Pages zu editieren,
Tabellen zu bearbeiten oder eine
Präsentation zu erstellen, da muss
man dann auch wirklich mit dem
Internet verbunden sein. Das ist
wahrscheinlich für die meisten
Leute auch der größte Unterschied
zu den Desktop-Programmen von
Microsoft und Apple. Google macht
das ein bisschen geschickter. Wer
Chrome oder Microsoft Edge verwendet,
kann auch offline mit Googles
Office Anwendung arbeiten.
Wir haben das Internet abgestellt.
Dann ging es aber in einen
Read-Only-Modus, der nach einer
Minute mit Internet wieder weg war.
Bei Apple kommt zwar schnell eine
Warnmeldung, die ist aber wirklich
nur eine Warnung. Das Arbeiten
funktioniert weiter, kann aber zu
Synchronisationsproblemen führen.
Deswegen solltet ihr, nachdem ihr
wieder online seid, immer auswählen,
welche Version ihr behalten wollt.
Auf den ersten Blick sehen die
Online-Versionen von Office und
iWork fast genauso aus wie die
Desktop-Varianten. Und das ist auch
der größte Vorteil. Wenn ihr eh
schon von der Arbeit oder Schule oder
Studium Word, Excel und Co. gewohnt
seid, dann könnt ihr das in einer
etwas abgespeckten Variante einfach
gratis im Browser weiter benutzen und
euch direkt zurechtfinden. Ihr
braucht nur einen normalen
Microsoft-Account. Also, wie gesagt,
ich fand das Angebot eigentlich gar
nicht so schlecht. Ich weiß nicht
mehr, was es im Jahr kostet.
Office plus Terabyte, OneDrive.
Ich fand es zumindest gut genug,
um es zu verkaufen.
Oder wenn von mir aus eure Eltern
nur mal ab und an mal ein Dokument
bearbeiten, Brief schreiben oder ein
Excel-Fahrtenbuch pflegen möchten,
dann können sie sich die 69 Euro
Jahres-Abo-Gebühr für Office auf
jeden Fall sparen, weil das eben
gratis geht. Wir haben euch übrigens
die Links zu allen erwähnten
Diensten unten verlinkt. Wichtig ist
zu wissen, der Funktionsumfang der
Online-Tools wird immer wieder
erweitert. Klassische Updates müsst
ihr dafür natürlich nicht machen.
Aber genau zu sagen, was alles
funktioniert und was nicht. Microsoft
gibt da auch keine Liste raus. Es
heißt einfach Premium-Features in der
Bezahlvariante. Ein großer
Unterschied, Makros, also so
Befehlsreihenfolgen zur
Automatisierung, werden vom Online-
Browser-Office nicht unterstützt. Oder
ganz banal, gibt Unterschiede in der
Ansichtsmöglichkeit. Während Word auf
dem Desktop so viele Fenster wie
möglich in einem Dokument anzeigt,
kann die Browser-Version gerade mal
mit Mühe zwei gleichzeitig anzeigen.
Kann die Online-Version von Word
auch nicht. So normale Word-Aufgaben
wie Briefschreiben, das geht natürlich
ohne Probleme. Mit allen drei
Programmen. Also nicht nur von
Microsoft, sondern auch von Apple und
Google. In manchen Fällen muss man
allerdings mit weniger Vorlieb nehmen.
Pages zum Beispiel kann Absatzstile,
also die klassischen Word-Format-
Verlagen, online zwar anwenden, aber
im Gegensatz zum Desktop kann man
keine neuen hinzufügen. Bei Word geht
das. Apples iWork in der Cloud...
benutze ich eh nicht. Wie gesagt,
das Einzige, was ich auf der Arbeit
verwende, ist PowerPoint ab und zu,
weil die halt drauf stehen, dass die
Präsentationen so Corporate-Design-
mäßig aussehen. Ja, wahrscheinlich
dürfte PowerPoint echt das meiste
benutzt zu sein. Für mich.
Word ist sowieso, sagen wir mal,
etwas gewöhnungsbedürftig in der
Bedienungsoberfläche und auf jeden Fall...
Außer Access. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob Access mittlerweile noch Standard
Bestandteil von Office ist. Das ist
der größte Schrott überhaupt. Ich
verstehe nicht, warum es das gibt.
Ja, aber Outlook ist nicht Office 365
Bestandteil. Da brauchst du ja einen
eigenen Service für. Guck, sonst hätte
ich jetzt ja Outlook installiert. Oh,
ich habe Outlook installiert. Ich habe
nichts gesagt. Ich dachte, das ist da
nicht dabei. Anscheinend doch. Okay,
wenn Access in Office, dann habe ich
sogar Access.
...gedacht, die gerade nur Zugriff auf
einen Linux- oder Windows-PC haben,
für die es eben keine Desktop-
Programme von iWork gerade gibt. Aber
auch wenn das nicht auf euch zutrifft,
könnte iWork im Browser für euch
interessant sein, denn da... Was hat er
da hinten eigentlich für ein nice
Kassettenradio stehen? Damit könnt ihr
eben alle iWork-Dokumente problemlos
öffnen, bearbeiten, drucken oder als PDF
oder Word-Datei herunterladen. Heißt,
wenn euch jemand eine .pages, .numbers
oder .keynote-Datei schickt, könnt ihr
damit jetzt endlich was anfangen. Mit
Word oder anderen Programmen kriegt ihr
die nämlich ohne Hilfsmittel nicht auf.
Mit Apples Online Office geht das
mehr als einfach. Die Leute sollen halt
einfach PDFs schicken, weil die kann jeder
auf jeder Plattform immer anzeigen. Die
meisten willst du ja nicht bearbeiten,
sondern anzeigen. Ich verstehe eh nicht,
warum man Doc-Dateien verschickt oder
Keynote-Dateien. Verschickt halt einfach
fucking PDFs. Ist nicht so, als gibt es
da irgendwelche Probleme mit.
...versenden möchte, also als PDF
downloaden, kann ich ihn auch direkt aus
dem Browser ausdrucken. Das funktionierte
bei unserem Test mit den Chrome- und
Edge-Browsern mit allen Online-Anbietern
ohne Probleme. Es öffnet sich einfach
das gleiche Dialogperiodie beim Drucken
von der Website und das entsprechende
Dokument ist dabei formatiert und kommt
den Erwartungen entsprechend aus dem
Drucker raus. Nutzt ihr andere Browser,
also zum Beispiel Firefox oder Safari,
müsst ihr einen Umweg über die PDF-Datei
nehmen. Das Online Office spuckt euch
vor dem Drucken eine PDF-Datei aus, die
ihr dann aufdruckt. Schon mal eine Rechnung
als Word-Dokument bekommen. Bestimmt. Kann
mich jetzt zwar niemand dran erinnern.
Bestimmt. Das ist dann so der Fall,
wo es gut ist, wenn man die Sachen direkt
im Browser öffnen kann, anstatt es
runterladen zu müssen und in einem
Office-Programm zu öffnen. Wobei ich das
auch prinzipiell nur in meiner Linux-VM
machen würde. Da weiß man ja nie.
Ein bisschen nervig ist es, in den
Online-Offices bestehende Dateien zu
öffnen, wenn man die auf dem Computer
gespeichert hat. Einfaches Doppel-
klicken reicht da nicht aus. Man kann
die Dateien halt nach OneDrive rüber
tracken und droppen und dann bearbeiten.
Momente müssen extra zum Anbieter
erfahren werden und sind dann in der
Cloud gespeichert. Das ist beim
Erstellen von Dateien im Browser auf
jeden Fall besser und um Backups muss
man sich dann auch keine Gedanken mehr
machen. Die Dateien sind einfach im
Cloud-Speicher des Anbieters gesichert.
Zwischen einem und 15 Gigabyte gibt es
da in den Gratis-Varianten. Die Details
seht ihr hier auch in der CT-Tabelle.
Das reicht ja auch, Dicke.
Gerade hier gibt es so viele super
special Anwendungen, die wir jetzt
natürlich nicht alle nachbauen und
ausprobieren können. Wir schauen uns
das mal in Excel mal gebaut.
Pass mal auf, oder in Word.
Excel Ray Tracing.
Ray Tracing in Excel.
Also, die machen schon abgedrehten
Shit, ne, manche Leute.
...deutschen Anwendungsfall an, das
punktgenaue Abrechnung nach einem
gemeinsamen Abendessen. Für dieses
Beispiel gehen wir mal davon aus, dass
fünf Leute gemeinsam essen und jeder
etwas dazu beiträgt. Auch in Excel
sehen wir die gewohnte Arbeitsoberfläche,
die man vom Desktop kennt. Google
hat es daraus aber doch irgendwie
ähnlich. Apples Numbers hat zwar eine
ganz andere Standardoberfläche. Die
gewohnten Befehle wie S-Verweis werden
aber übersichtlich an der Seite
angezeichnet, nachdem man ein
Gleichzeichen in die Tabelle getippt
hat. Für so normale Sachen wie unser
Abrechnungsbeispiel sind alle drei
Programme geeignet. Wir können uns
hier sogar schöne Grafiken erstellen
lassen und genau sehen, wie viel zum
Essen beigetragen wird. Endlich, so ein
geiles Tortendiagramm. Hier im Desktop
gibt es auch online Vorlagen für
Apples, die natürlich etwas mehr zu
bieten als die anderen beiden. Auch wenn
ich jetzt wieder in alte Klischees
verfalle, diese Vorlagen bei Apple
sehen einfach mehr aus wie
Grafikdesigner erstellten Rechnungen
als die Controller BWL Optik in Excel.
Aber das ist ja auch Geschmackssache.
Und es geht ja auch nicht nur ums
Design. Bei Präsentationen ist Design
schon mehr ein Thema und das haben die
Office-Anbieter in den letzten Jahren
deutlich besser gemacht mit KI. Die
Möglichkeit mit Design-Vorschlägen
eigentlich nur noch Wörter zahlen und
das hat das Ausstellen von
Präsentationen auf jeden Fall
erleichtert. Das Gute, auch die
Online-Programme können das, wenn auch
etwas eingeschränkter. Ich gebe hier
jetzt einfach mal ein, Katzen sind süß
und hier, wie Katzen ein
Internetphänomen wurden. Und schon
schlägt mir PowerPoint hier an der
Seite Designs mittels KI vor. Das ist
eigentlich ganz cool. In der Entfalten
Variante kriege ich sogar direkt ein
Bild mit vorgeschlagen. In der
Gratis-Version muss ich dafür erst
auf Bilder klicken und kann dann über
das Display klicken. Das sieht dann
aus wie eine Präsentation von
1995.
Es steht direkt Bilder, die unter
Creative Commons fallen, auszuwählen.
Apple kann zwar auch Design-Vorschläge,
aber nicht aus dem Browser heraus nach
Bildern aus dem Internet suchen.
Worin sich PowerPoint im Browser stark
von der Desktop-Variante unterscheidet,
ist der Präsentationsmodus. Also
eigentlich nicht ganz unwichtig. Im
Browser habt ihr nämlich keine
Referentenansicht. Ihr seht also auch
nur die aktuelle Folie und entsprechend
auch nicht die Notizen. Apple und
Google bieten aber eine Referentenansicht
im Browser. Also mein Fazit. Einfache
Office-Aufgaben für Zuhause kann man auf
jeden Fall mit allen drei Anbietern ganz
gut hinbekommen. Das ist dann
letztendlich so ein bisschen die
Gewohnheit. Wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel
nur Apple-Geräte habt und sowieso
Pages, Numbers und so weiter, dann
braucht ihr eigentlich nur ein
Referentenansicht im Browser.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel
nur Apple-Geräte habt und sowieso
Numbers und Keynotes verwendet, klar,
dann könnt ihr das auch online
verwenden, wenn ihr mal auf dem
Windows- oder Linux-PC unterwegs sein
solltet. Wenn ihr eh schon Google Mail
und Kalender im Browser verwendet, dann
ist natürlich irgendwie Google Docs
naheliegend. Da funktioniert das
Zusammenarbeiten mit anderen wirklich
super. Und ihr könnt das auch offline
verwenden. Und solange das
Offline-Arbeiten bei Microsoft 365 ein
Premium-Feature bleibt, ist das Online-
Office die beste Möglichkeit, um in
einem gewohnten Umfeld Office zu
arbeiten.
Schnell hat das Microsoft Office von
allen drei Angeboten den größten
Funktionsumfang. In Sachen Bedienung
fanden wir die Google-Produkte am
eingängigsten. Wenn man allerdings die
Offline-Office-Programme von Apple oder
Microsoft in- und auswendig kennt,
fühlt man sich da auch in den Online-
Varianten schnell zu Hause. Ach ja,
ganz wichtig, ihr solltet immer im
Hinterkopf behalten, dass alle drei
Anbieter in den USA sitzen und die
eure Daten auch, zumindest teilweise,
dort speichern. Wenn ihr das
Office-Sachen weiterhin offline
machen, da gibt es ja auch ordentliche
Open-Source-Alternativen, LibreOffice
oder OnlyOffice zum Beispiel. Ja, wie
ist das bei euch? Benutzt ihr Office-Zeug
schon längst im Browser oder seid ihr
immer noch ganz klassisch mit der
Desktop-Variante unterwegs? Und welches
Office-Programm benutzt ihr am liebsten?
Schreibt das gerne in die Kommentare,
freuen uns über Wir lesen alles und
natürlich auch gerne abonnieren.
Tschüss!
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ja, okay, Paints Champ Bits, ihr habt
recht.
Unbelievable Making of Battle Bits.
Ja, das reicht jetzt, was wir geguckt
haben.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Komm, wir refreshen YouTube jetzt
fünfmal und gucken, ob was
Gescheites angezeigt ist. Zwei, drei,
es ist immer das Gleiche.
What the fuck?
Fünf.
Es ist einfach immer exakt das
Gleiche, was angezeigt wird.
Oh, guck mal, ich kriege meine eigenen
Videos empfohlen, Pong.
Muss ich anklicken für View-Time.
Auslassen. Ich weiß, dass viele,
vor allem war Informatik.
Wait a minute.
Der Titel dieses Videos
erinnert
mich fast ein bisschen an meins.
Ist das nicht der, der reacted hat
auf mein Video?
Im halben Jahr habe ich ein Video
gemacht, zehn Gründe, warum man
Linux nutzen sollte.
Ist das nicht der, der auch auf
mein Video reacted hat, wo es um
das Thema ging, Linux ist kein
Windows-Ersatz oder sowas in der
Richtung?
Doch, doch, ich glaube schon.
Ich finde es aber gerade nicht.
Da war es.
Chat, wo?
Ach hier, das.
Ich will mal gucken, ob es
irgendwelche neuen blöden
Comments gibt. Das ist immer ganz
witzig da zu lesen, was die Leute
für Blödsinn schreiben.
Hier, Wall of Text.
Ich gehe oft mit.
Das ist ein richtiger
VM-Enjoyer.
Primär Windows, Linux in einer
VM. Der weiß Bescheid.
Alter!
Das ist ja Wall of Text hier.
Okay, es sind keine so richtig.
Also das Video ist vollkommen okay
gewesen, aber die Comments sind
teilweise richtig dämlich.
Aber das hier, es geht ja alles.
Es gibt kaum noch neue richtige
Cringe-Comments.
Gibt es unter meinem Video
irgendwas? Ach ne, das Video
wurde nicht verlinkt, oder?
Es gab irgendwelche blöden neuen
Comments.
Linux bebt das größte Problem auf
allen PCs, Microsoft.
Naja.
Wenn man das für sich als
größtes Problem sieht.
Selten, okay, okay, jetzt kommt
die Erklärung.
War doch klar, dass es wieder
irgendwelche bescheuerten Comments
gibt. Okay.
Selten so ein Quatsch gehört.
Da werden Administrator-Aufgaben
Linux mit normalen User-Tasks
Windows verglichen.
Naja.
Es gibt ja auch nur eine Person,
die sich da drum kümmert.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als hast du
daheim eine IT-Abteilung, die alle
administrativen Tasks für dich
erledigt und dich nur noch um reine
User-Tasks kümmern kannst.
Du bist Admin und User in einem.
Habe Windows seit 20 Jahren in den
Rücken gekehrt und brauche das
Terminal so selten wie...
Ja, dann sieht man schon mal, dass
kein ordentlicher Linux-User ist,
weil Linux-User mögen in der Regel
das Terminal und kennen sich da auch
gut aus und wissen, dass man über
das Terminal Sachen einfach
angenehmer erledigen kann.
Ich brauche meinen Computer auch
zum Arbeiten, gespielt wird mit
der Konsole.
Ich denke, er verwendet kein
Terminal.
Ja, okay, ich weiß, was er meint.
Ja, okay.
Wenn er auf seinem Computer nichts
macht, was...
wofür er Windows braucht, dann ist
er schön und gut, ja.
Aber das war ja gar nicht der Punkt
in dem Video.
Wenn du nur auf der Konsole spielst
und nichts machst von dem, was
Windows quasi besser macht, ja,
dann kannst du auch Linux verwenden.
Das ist doch klar.
Das muss man dann wollen, weil
das muss man dann wollen, wenn es
im Tuna oder Nautilus oder sonst
wo nicht auftaucht, ja.
Es gibt...
Das stimmt, ne.
Ja, okay, man kann sich bestimmt
über die Blender-Bedienung
ärgern.
Aber Blender ist, würde ich mal
behaupten, eigentlich im
professionellen Entwicklungsumfeld
heute schon
durch die Bank weg angekommen.
Der Typ ist auch geil gewesen,
hier das Comment.
Linuxguides.de lässt dich
schlecht dastehen.
Er nimmt das Video hier unsachlich
aus.
Ich würde dir anraten, rechtlich
vorzugehen.
Dazu, dazu kann ich nur
sagen, Moment.
Zu diesem, zu diesem Video kann
ich echt nur sagen, zu diesem
Comment kann ich echt nur sagen.
Direkt anzeigen.
Immer anzeigen, alle.
Ich find das so geil
zusammengeschnitten, Alter.
Ich könnte mich da immer wegspatzen.
Ja, alles andere fällt mir zu dem
Comment echt nicht mehr ein.
So.
Vielleicht nachher.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Ein Geomatiker?
Das hat nichts mit einem
Informatiker zu tun,
vermute ich mal, oder?
Was macht ein Geomatiker
im Büro und auf der Baustelle?
Ne, und auf Baustellen.
Beruf und Galt eines
Geomatikers bei den
Stadtwerken.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Das ist falsch geschrieben.
Ja, man schreibt das eigentlich mit
einem O hier hinten, wissen wir ja
alle.
Das ist ein Geomatikor.
Okay, ich glaube, dass es Berufe
gibt, die mehr verdienen.
Seriously, ich glaube, das ist in
jedem Beruf so.
Egal, was du machst, es wird
immer Berufe geben, die mehr
verdienen.
Die mehr verdienen.
Wir messen jetzt mal auf.
3,60 Meter Höhe.
Wir haben immer einen gewissen
Zeitdruck beim Aufnehmen der
Baustellen.
Präzision schlecht.
Er braucht ein bisschen Grad.
Hallo zusammen.
Mein Name ist Markus
Geomatikor.
Ich bin Leiter der Netzdokumentation
der Stadtwerke Neuburg an der
Donau.
Haben die auch was mit
Glasfaserverlegung zu tun?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Ich würde euch heute zeigen, wie
bei mir im Job Genauigkeit so
wichtig ist.
Let's go.
Willkommen in meinem Büro.
Gurken aus dem Garten.
Einmal Gurken.
Das ist unser Mittagessen.
Wir machen heute
griechischen Salat.
Wir vermessen heute auf jeden
Fall Wärmebaustelle.
Dann werden wir ein bisschen
Bürokram haben.
Dann müssen wir einen neuen
Wärmeplan erstellen, wie hier.
Plus aktuell.
Bei uns in der
Netzdokumentation erstellen wir
ein digitales Abbild dessen, was
wir in der Erde vergraben,
Anleitungen.
Das wäre, glaube ich, so die
kürzeste Beschreibung dafür.
Das ist jetzt klassischerweise
unser Webgis.
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie
Google Earth.
Der große Unterschied ist
sozusagen, dass wir...
Fehlt noch ein bisschen Streetview.
Okay, es sieht aus wie ein
nicht so hoch aufgelöstes
Google Earth, aber
der Vergleich lässt sich mir
gefallen.
...aktiven Baumaßnahmen haben,
wo gerade gebaut sind, sind die
roten Flächen.
Also hier ist der Schema
blanched rum.
Hier sieht man die
verschiedenen Kabeltypen, die
praktisch verbaut sind.
Leute, kein SSL, kein DNS
direkt auf die IP.
Was ist da los?
Es ist ein Großteil meiner
Arbeit besteht letztendlich darin,
diese Attribute...
Es ist aber noch Windows 7,
oder?
Ist es noch Windows 7?
Ich glaube schon, oder?
Windows 10?
Ja, ja, okay.
Windows 10.
...ist zu erfassen.
Wenn wir Daten ungenau
aufnehmen, könnte es dazu
kommen, dass die Leitungen
ungenau ins Planwerk
logischerweise übernommen
werden.
Der Baggerfahrer könnte
denken, dass an dieser Stelle
keine Leitungen sind.
Das ist dann...
Dann passiert das, was
letztens in Frankfurt war, wo
irgendein Bagger Glasfaser
durchgebaggert hat.
...einsetzen, die Leitung
aufreißen und dann kann es
eben zu Verletzten kommen, wenn
man eben eine Heißwasserleitung
erwischt oder so.
Also, was interessiert mich
für Letzte, wenn mein
Internet ausfällt?
Das ist das eigentliche
Problem.
Mal auf die Baustelle.
Fahr mal.
Einfach, weil das Aufnehmen
am Graben draußen, in einem
tiefen Graben zu zweit
deutlich sicherer ist.
Das ist für uns tatsächlich
mit einer der wichtigsten
Baustellen im Moment, weil
das unsere Hauptwärme-
Versorgungssysteme sind.
Das heißt, wir haben
eine sehr, sehr
wichtige Baustelle.
Wir haben eine sehr, sehr
Genauigkeit ist das, was
ein Geomatiker-Vermesser
auszeichnet im Arbeiten,
weil wir eben versuchen...
Im Namen Vermesser steckt es
ja schon irgendwie drin,
dass du da sehr ordentlich
und genau sein musst.
Also schon mal nichts
für mich Athen oder
angefühlt in Zampen.
...und auch gesetzlich
die Vorgabe haben, eben
Leitungen auf ein sehr
hohes Maß an Genauigkeit
wieder rekonstruierbar
zu machen.
Grundsätzlich schlecht wäre,
wenn man mit GPS vermisst,
sozusagen, wenn man eine
Baustelle hat, die komplett
unter dem Blätterdach ist.
Also jetzt im Wald messen
ist tatsächlich eine
gewisse Herausforderung.
Die Genauigkeit hängt
von der Anzahl
der Satelliten ab.
Die Antenne braucht
einen direkten Kontakt
zum Satelliten.
Das ist unser
Vermessungskopf.
Damit werden praktisch
nahe die Satelliten
eingefangen.
Und da bauen wir jetzt
noch eine Verlängerung drauf,
weil es ein paar Bäume hat.
Das heißt, wir messen
jetzt mal auf
3,60 Meter Höhe.
3,60 Meter haben wir.
Jetzt sieht man hier
praktisch wie viele Satelliten
das wir gerade
als Empfang haben.
Hier oben ist die Anzahl
der Satelliten.
Also unter 10 Satelliten
wird es tatsächlich
ein bisschen schwierig.
Dann gehen wir jetzt mal
zum Messen.
Kannst du nochmal?
Wir legen jetzt fest,
was für eine Leitung das ist.
Also Vorlauf.
Es gibt in der Wärme
gibt es praktisch Vorlauf
und Rücklauf.
Machen wir noch
ein Foto dazu.
Das wirkt aber
trotzdem sehr gechillt.
Ja, Chat,
sehe ich auch so.
Jetzt geht es dann hoch
und da werden die ganzen
Schweißnähte aufgenommen,
weil Schweißnähte
immer potenzielle
Schwachstellen sind
in der Leitung.
Boah, da hast du aber
was zu tun.
Wir sind schon
so, dass wir nicht
alle vier studiert haben
bei uns.
Ich denke, dass es aber
eben auch Bereiche gibt
wie Webmapping.
Okay, das ist aber
echt nicht viel.
Ich habe da kaum was übrig.
Datenbankstrukturierung
und solche Geschichten,
die durchaus
anspruchsvoll sind
und die eben auch
jetzt nicht zwangsweise
ins Studium voraussetzen,
um Gottes Willen.
Es gibt bestimmt Menschen,
die das auch so können,
aber wo es auch nicht schadet.
Präzision schlecht.
Er braucht ein bisschen
gerade, weil hier
Bäume sind
und dann braucht er
ein bisschen,
bis er die Präzision hat,
die wir gerne hätten.
Wir haben immer
einen gewissen
Zeitdruck beim Aufnehmen
der Baustellen.
Weil die Baufirmen
in der Regel
darauf warten,
dass wir kommen.
Wir sind das letzte
Gewerk sozusagen
von den Stadtwerken,
bevor die Leitung
wieder verfüllt wird.
Deshalb darf es
beim Aufnehmen der Leitung
eigentlich nicht
zu Verzögerungen kommen.
Das ist einfach.
Ist GPS echt so anfällig?
Naja,
die wollen das ja wahrscheinlich
wirklich so exakt
wie möglich haben.
Ich meine,
ich habe mal irgendwo gelesen,
dass du unter sieben Satelliten
es gibt,
unter sieben Satelliten
es gar nicht
halbwegs genau hinbekommst.
Und die wollen anscheinend
irgendwie zehn, elf haben.
Ja,
naja,
kann schon sein.
Ein Kostenfaktor
für die Baufirmen passt.
Beobachtung gespeichert.
Fertig,
GPS vermessen.
Jetzt machen wir
noch eine 3D-Aufnahme
von der Baustelle.
Mit dem Equipment
arbeite ich...
Das ist ja nicht wirklich
GPS, was anfällig ist,
sondern der Empfang.
Das ist auch immer das,
was ich immer witzig fand,
früher,
oder es wird ja heute
immer noch gemacht,
in Filmen teilweise,
so nach dem Motto,
wir orten ihn über GPS.
Da musst du immer
eine Runde kacken,
weil du halt über GPS
niemanden orten kannst.
Aber das macht sich halt
in irgendwelchen Krimis
und Filmen gut,
so nach dem Motto,
ah, wir haben ihn hier
auf der Map,
wir orten ihn über GPS.
Nein, nein, nein,
so funktioniert,
ist das nicht gedacht,
ja, das funktioniert so nicht.
...man schon länger
und das andere ist so,
dass tatsächlich...
GPS ist quasi
Read Only, könnte man sagen.
Ja, das, was rauskommt,
schon noch immer
ein bisschen eine Überraschung ist
und weil es einfach
interessant ist
und weil es ja,
wie alles, was man neu hat,
immer ein bisschen
aufregend ist.
Das ist auch eine GPS-Antenne,
praktisch wie unser Kopf.
250 Millionen,
Porc, danke schön,
für die Bits.
Wie ihr vorhin gesehen habt.
Nur, dass der halt
viel, viel kleiner ist
und auch jetzt
am iPhone Pro draufhängt,
um sozusagen
die Positionsgenauigkeit
des iPhones entsprechend
zu verbessern.
Das iPhone Pro hat
einen eingebauten
LiDAR-Scanner
und den machen wir jetzt
in dem Fall zunutze.
Jetzt hat er einen Moment
hier mit dem Chat.
Ich warte noch drauf,
bis irgendwann mal kommt,
lohnt sich das
Gender Study
oder irgendwie sowas.
Würde ich denen auch zutrauen.
Ne, aber ich gucke das,
gucke das wirklich ganz gerne.
Da hast du ja auch oftmals
Berufe,
von denen hast du
nie was gehört.
Ich wusste bis jetzt nicht mal,
dass es ein Geomatikor
überhaupt gibt.
Sechs Satelliten,
jetzt sieht man auch,
die Anzahl der Satelliten
steigt jetzt
und die Genauigkeit
verbessert sich entsprechend.
Und dann gehe ich nachher
einfach auf Aufnahme
und laufe über die Baustelle
und im besten Fall
habe ich nachher
ein 3D-Bild davon.
TOS, TOS, TOS, TOS,
TOS, TOS, TOS,
So, das war's auch schon.
Wir fahren jetzt rein,
laden die Daten hoch
und dann wird es
so 40 Minuten dauern.
Wie geht das denn
mit mein iPhone finden?
Ja, mein iPhone finden
ist ein bisschen,
ein bisschen mehr pfeifen.
Das ist ähnlich zu
wie funktionieren AirTags
und zwar die Position
wird über GPS ermittelt.
Aber das bringt nichts,
weil die GPS-Position
ermittelst du immer
auf dem Empfänger.
Also es ist nicht
irgendwie der Satellit,
der die Position
vom Empfänger bestimmt,
Empfänger, der sich die Position anhand der Satelliteninformationen errechnet, also dein Handy kann GPS empfangen und daraus seine Position
errechnen, das heißt du brauchst für GPS, um jemanden zu tracken, um was zu finden, immer noch einen weiteren
Sendekanal und bei AirTags ist es so, dass alle iPhones, die in der Nähe sind und dieses Signal bekommen, das quasi weiter
weiter Relayen zum Apple-Server.
Das ist alles und so funktioniert FindMeiniPhone auch. Ich glaube, du kannst Opt-out machen dafür,
aber dann kannst du keine AirTags mehr verwenden oder irgendwie sowas. Also das ist nicht gedacht dafür zu Opt-outen.
Aber weiß Apple, wo sich welches Gerät befindet, das weiß ich nicht,
ob das verschlüsselt übertragen wird und Apple das nicht sieht, aber potenziell muss es Apple sehen können,
weil Apple dir das ja auch ausliefert letztendlich, also
ja
wahrscheinlich schon. Ohne das iPhone sendet halt, ja das geht natürlich auch, ja.
Aber wenn das nicht möglich sein sollte, bei AirTags wird das halt über, ich glaube, Bluetooth, Low Energy Bluetooth, wird quasi ein Signal rausgeschickt.
iPhones fangen das auf und Relayen das dann quasi weiter an Apple-Server über Wi-Fi oder Mobilfunk.
Wie ist das eigentlich auf dem Land, wenn keine oder wenig andere Apple, da hast du gelitten.
Also wenn du einen AirTag hast, irgendwo, wo kein iPhone jemals vorbeikommt, wirst du den auch nicht finden.
Und dann sehen wir uns das Endergebnis an, denke ich.
Als Geomatiker hier bei den Stadtwerken bist du wirklich draußen,
als Kartograf im klassischen Sinne, da bist du nur im Büro und
machst eben deine Recherche, so wie es ein Buchautor auch macht, zu Straßen, Wegen, Zielen. Boah, das fände ich ja langweilig als Fuck.
Jacke aufhängen.
So, und jetzt laden wir es schon hoch in die Cloud. Sobald es fertig ist, kriege ich eine Mail und dann gucken wir
in die Behörden-Cloud.
Wie lange hält so ein AirTag, weiß ich nicht.
Ich würde mal auf ein Ja oder so tippen, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Wird jetzt auch erst mal GPS-Bestimmung gemacht, für den er den Urlaubsantrag geschickt hat.
Wir gucken mal, ob wir schon so weit sind. Es sollte
so sein, dass ich die Rohre erkennen kann, dass ich das Ganze in 3D habe.
Ich finde das... Cool!
Das ist doch nice!
Einfach mal ein bisschen gescannt und drüber langgelaufen und schon hast du ein 3D-Bild.
Das ist ganz gut geworden.
Das ist ja cool. Man sieht einfach relativ gut die Struktur, man kann innerhalb des Bildes gleich relativ gut messen,
relativ gut die Grabenbreiten festlegen. Das ist auch realistisch vom Wert her.
Hier hast du keine Information, weil du es ja nicht von unten siehst.
Es ist aber trotzdem, denke ich, wirklich sehr schön geworden.
Also, Mittag einmal.
Mahlzeit!
Ein Glück, dass ihr es mir heute so wunderschön gemacht habt.
Wir haben noch ein paar Pläne zu erstellen.
Die Leute sollen einen schönen Überblick darüber haben,
in welchem Jahr was in der Stadt sozusagen an Baustellen auf sie zukommt.
Alles, was man jetzt in grün sieht, ist das, was sozusagen ein Leitungsnetz schon da ist.
Lila ist das, was nächstes Jahr geplant ist.
Da hat sich jetzt eine Menge geändert und darum muss man das jetzt noch ein bisschen anpassen.
Aha!
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich Zeichnen.
Das Berufsbild des Geomatikers ist ja relativ weitläufig.
Da geht es ja eben auch um große Analysen von Umweltveränderungen, von Trockenheit, Dürre, Lärmbelastung.
Gut, dann haben wir das soweit fertig.
Ich glaube, mir wäre das zu Resident Sleeper.
16.30 Uhr? Okay, da bin ich schon eine Stunde, eine halbe Stunde bis Stunde weg.
Einen schönen Feierabend, die Herren.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Pfiat euch!
Servus!
Ich verdiene ungefähr 4.800 Euro brutto und mir bleiben 3.000.
Das geht doch vollkommen klar.
Ich denke auch, dass das Gehalt angemessen ist.
Am Anfang stand doch viel weniger.
Es gibt Berufe, die mehr verdienen und eine hohe Verantwortung haben.
Und es gibt auch Berufe, die eine wahnsinnige Verantwortung haben und viel weniger verdienen.
Ich finde, dass es bei mir jetzt im Besonderen passt.
Wow, die Teile sind halt richtig teuer.
Man sieht aber unglaublich viele Räder mit Akku mittlerweile.
Ich würde fast so weit gehen und sagen, dass gefühlt ein Drittel oder ein Viertel der Räder sind elektrisch.
Man sieht enorm viele.
Immer wenn ich am Main lang laufe, fährt irgendjemand mit Akkudüste an mir vorbei.
Letztens kam mir so eine Oma entgegen, die Brücke hoch.
Da geht es relativ steil hoch.
Und die ist da mit 30 km in der Stunde die Brücke hochgeflitzt.
Ich sage mir, Alter, was ist mit der Oma los?
Und die sitzt und tritt kaum.
Und dann fährt die halt an mir vorbei und sagt, okay, Akku, alles klar.
Im Leben wäre die da normalerweise gar nicht hochgeflitzt und vor allem nicht in dem Speed.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie schnell es wirklich war, aber es war wirklich schon sehr zackig.
Und vor allem berghoch.
Was, die Fahrräder steigen bei 25 kmh aus?
Das kann eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Aber du kannst noch zusätzlich treten, oder?
Mit 25 kmh kommst du ja auch nirgendswo gescheit hin.
Auf längere Strecken.
Der Motor unterstützt sich nicht mehr.
Wenn ich mit 25 kmh nach Frankfurt fahren würde, dann brauche ich da viel zu lang für.
Guck mal, das sind ungefähr 40 km nach Frankfurt.
Da brauche ich 1,40 oder so.
Also, bis dann.
Also das Haus, in dem ich wohne, das haben wir halbfertig geerbt und dann letztendlich fertig gebaut.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Oh ja, meine Süße.
Das ist unser Hund, Winnie.
Diese zweijährige Labrador-Hündin.
Viel Spaß, viel Arbeit, viel spazieren gehen, aber schon auch eine Bereicherung.
Wir sind jetzt drei, vorher waren wir vier, meine Tochter ist ausgezogen.
Meine Frau Claudia und mein Sohn Tim wohnen hier noch.
Also ein Teil der Bilder, wie das hier zum Beispiel, sind von meinem Vater gemacht.
Und grundsätzlich habe ich halt ein Faible für Lithographien.
Also es hat wahrscheinlich auch wieder was mit Kathografie zu tun, weil das ja auch so eine verwandte Technik ist im eigentlichen Sinne.
Jetzt ist es so, dass es für mich das ist, was ich mir vorstelle, dass ich aus dem Haus gehe und im Wald und im Grünen bin.
Das ist tatsächlich so das, was mir in der Stadt fehlen wird.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich auch jeden Tag so eineinhalb Stunden meistens ein bisschen außerhalb unterwegs bin.
Ein bisschen durch irgendwelche Felder laufen, Wälder laufen, das ist einfach angenehm.
Also wenn das immer so gechillt ist, denke ich, kann man eindeutig sagen, das lohnt sich.
Ist jetzt zwar nicht super krass, aber...
Oh nee, ist mein Browser wieder kaputt?
Leute, ich glaube mein...
Was ist das denn? Warum geht immer einmal im Stream mein Browser kaputt?
Was ist da los?
Muss ich doch Edge verwenden wieder?
Ich habe noch nie Edge verwendet, aber...
Was ist das? Was ist da los?
Oh, das hätte ich gar nicht zumachen müssen, das war hier der Chat.
RAM voll? Ja, bestimmt, das wird es sein.
Ganz bestimmt, Leute, RAM voll.
Ich zeige euch, wie voll mein RAM ist.
Ist fast am Limit, der RAM, würde ich sagen.
Nicht mal viel Platz.
Aber die Tabs machen doch nichts.
Was soll das Problem an Tabs sein?
Ich kriege langsam schon Hunger, Leute.
Das ist problematisch, es ist erst 10.40 Uhr.
Chat, ratet mal, was es heute gibt.
Na, wenn RAM kaputt ist, dann crasht der Rechner, nicht sowas.
Was gibt es heute zu essen? Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Lachs mit Nudeln? Nein, nein, es gibt Spaghetti.
Ich habe es am Anfang schon erzählt, ja.
Nein, nein, es gibt Spaghetti, aber heute nicht mit Lachs.
Heute nicht mit Lachs.
Oh, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Das dunkle Geheimnis von Kik.
Oh, guck mal, ich kriege mein eigenes Video empfohlen.
Extremly Pog.
Das haben wir schon geguckt, oder?
Ja, aber daran liegt das nicht, dass mein Chrome hängt.
Das macht er auch witzigerweise nur hier auf dem anderen Account nicht.
Ja, Spaghetti Bolognese.
Mein Arbeitslaptop ist lahm als Fuck, obwohl er 32GB RAM hat und ein i7.
Weil so viel Security Mist im Hintergrund läuft.
Irgendwie 20 Security Programme.
Wieso man die alle braucht, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Okay, das dunkle Geheimnis von Kik.
War es das mit Twitch? Also ihr kennt meine Meinung dazu.
Also erstens, das war es garantiert nicht mit Twitch.
Und ich muss euch sagen, von der Plattform her finde ich Twitch auch um einiges angenehmer.
Also als zum Gucken, ja.
Dass Twitch auch so seine Probleme hat, gerade was die Auslegung von Regeln angeht und sowas,
will ich gar nicht bestreiten, das ist auch sehr undurchsichtig alles.
Aber Kik wirkt halt einfach wie so eine...
So ein bisschen...
So die bisschen zwielichtigere Kopie von Twitch.
Ich glaube, das trifft es ganz gut, weil wenn man das aufmacht,
das erste was man sieht, ist erstmal gefühlt nur Gambling und ein bisschen Gaming.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass sich Kik in diesem Bereich auch irgendwie etabliert.
Was Kik wahrscheinlich auch ganz recht ist, weil die unter der Haube ja Geld mit Glücksspiel verdienen.
Und dass man nicht direkt mit Twitch konkurrieren kann,
so auf dieser breiten Gaming-Front, so Family-Friendly-Gaming-Streaming-Plattform.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht richtig möglich.
Deswegen versucht man wahrscheinlich eher so auf die Gambling-Schiene
oder vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen Leute, die bei Twitch halt nicht mehr so gerne gesehen sind,
dort irgendwie unterzubringen. Die bringen ja auch Leute rein.
Und unterm Strich wird es Kik wahrscheinlich darum gehen,
dass die Leute halt auf ihrem Gambling-Kram Geld ausgeben.
Also, ich persönlich glaube ja nicht dran, dass Kik das Ende von Twitch ist.
Einer der größten Twitch-Streamer überhaupt mit über 11,8 Millionen Twitch-Followern
ist jetzt weg von Twitch.
Also, ist der weg von Twitch? Ich dachte, das ist gar nicht exklusiv.
Ne, er ist offensichtlich nicht weg von Twitch.
Er war vor 11 Stunden noch on.
Da sieht man mal, dass diese Seiten halt viel Mist schreiben, wenn der Tag lange ist, ja.
Gucken wir dann auch nicht.
Weil, das war eines der ersten Sachen, wo ich auch falsch verstanden habe.
Ich habe auch gedacht, das wäre so ein Ninja-Exklusiv-Deal,
aber wenn man sich das da mal ein bisschen genauer anguckt,
hat man festgestellt, nee, ist es nicht.
Es ist eigentlich eher so eine Promo-Aktion, ja, aber nicht exklusiv.
Ja, das ist halt auch das Ding.
Microsoft hat halt versucht, Twitch Konkurrenz zu machen
als so Family-Friendly-Streaming-Gaming-Streaming-Plattform, wie Twitch ist.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Wenn Kik eher so diese, sagen wir mal, Grauzonen-Streams und Gambling-Streams fördert,
kann das durchaus eine Lücke sein, die Twitch nicht abdeckt und dort sehr erfolgreich wird.
Okay.
Verständlich, ja, die wollen ja Leute mit rübernehmen, mit rüberholen, verständlich, ja.
Na komm, gucken wir uns das Video trotzdem an.
Ups, ne, gucken wir nicht, ich finde es nicht mehr.
Also, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das so ist.
Alter, Jackfrax, was ist das für eine Überschrift?
Battle.Bit is ruining every other game.
Ja, Leute, ich wusste nicht, ob ihr es schon gehört habt.
Also, seit Battle.Bit raus ist, spielt keiner mehr Fortnite und Apex.
Das ist alles dead.
Spielen alle nur noch Battle.Bit.
Battle.Bit hat auf einmal 8 Millionen Spieler.
Bei Jackfrax habt ihr es zuerst gehört, Leute.
Heli flog nach Frankfurt.
Er ist mal ins Ghetto geflogen.
Hauptbahnhof.
Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, Zaldi-Kollektion-Bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Wir könnten noch eine Runde Fireship gucken.
Boah, ich habe echt keinen Plan, irgendwie interessieren mich die ganzen Videos gerade nicht.
Chat, habt ihr irgendwas Spannendes, was wir uns noch geben könnten?
Was wir uns noch geben könnten?
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt einfach was essen.
Um 10.45 Uhr.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Das war Haftbefehl, ja.
Zu langsam. Es spielt sich nicht wie Battlefield.
Es spielt sich auf jeden Fall langsamer.
Aber ich habe gerade im Chat gelernt, dass der Entwickler Battlefield spielt
und der andere Entwickler Squad.
Und dann passt das wieder.
Gar nicht. Gar nicht.
Lass mich mal kurz was checken.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt...
SaatchenSilver, danke für den PogSub.
Ja, 40 Minuten gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an.
Der Titel allein schon.
Ne.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf. Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Wir spielen heute Abend wahrscheinlich...
Mein eigenes Video.
Gute Idee, gute Idee. Was ist das?
Wie man das Internet zerstört.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt doch gucken. Ich gehe doch nicht auf.
Okay.
Wie zerstört man eigentlich das Internet?
Das können wir noch gucken. Acht Minuten, ja.
Wie zerstört man eigentlich...
Ich frage für einen Freund...
Okay, es ist relativ einfach das Internet zu zerstören.
Hat man gesehen.
Man braucht einfach nur einen Router,
falsche BGP-Advertisements machen zu lassen.
Und dann geht das schon nicht richtig.
Kam die letzten Jahre über immer mal wieder vor.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
was da jetzt rauskommt.
Wenn ich das Internet zerstören wollen würde,
wie würde man das anstellen?
Ich frage für einen Freund.
Jetzt mal ehrlich. Kann man?
Ja, kann man.
Also man selber daheim,
je nachdem, wie man Zerstören sieht,
eher schwierig.
Aber wenn man bei einem Provider arbeitet
und sein Edge-Routers irgendwie falsch konfiguriert,
dann ja.
Alternativ,
natürlich könntest du auch
ein Ordner der Geschichte bauen
und alles lahmlegen.
Das wäre dann aber etwas illegal
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht im Skill-Bereich
der meisten Leute.
Also, naja, mal gucken.
Man kann.
Also, eure Oma vielleicht nicht.
Es sei denn, sie kann Bagger fahren.
Naja, wir haben uns angeschaut,
wie man das Internet kaputt machen könnte
und bringen euch das wahrscheinlich unterhaltsamste
Weltuntergangs-Video, das wir je gemacht haben.
Warum kann ich dieses Video nicht veröffentlichen?
Hast du versucht, es wieder aufzutauschen?
Warum mag niemand meine Posts?
Nein! Gott, bitte nein!
Es begann alles damit,
dass wir Internet-Zerstörung gegoogelt haben
und das sofort bereut haben,
weil das eine ganz schlechte Minute ist.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen weiter sucht,
kann man tatsächlich herausfinden,
wie man das Internet selber theoretisch abschalten könnte.
Long story short, es gibt davon
verschiedene Möglichkeiten,
von sehr kompliziert bis zu sehr einfach.
Also, ihr geht in den Baumarkt,
kauft euch eine Axt,
eine Axt, alles klar,
und buddelt eines der weltumspannenden Untersee-Kabel
dort aus, wo sie an Land treffen.
Naja, das ist jetzt nicht sonderlich praktikabel.
Da ist so ein BGP falsch konfiguriert
auf irgendeinem Provider-Router.
Wo war das letzte Mal in Tschechien oder so
irgendein Router, der falsch konfiguriert war,
schon etwas effektiver?
Warum musst du immer so rein, raus bei OBS?
Ich will gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt.
Das weiß man ja bei Windows immer nicht so genau.
Hier zum Beispiel, oder hier.
Denn das Internet funktioniert nicht mal halb so kabellos,
wie unser WLAN uns das glauben machen will.
Ach nee!
Die großen Datenströme dieser Welt
zwischen den Ländern und Kontinenten
fließen alle durch Untersee-Kabel.
Großbritannien hat einige, da müsst ihr dir viel graben.
Für Westafrika hingegen
reicht ein einzelner Schnitt an der richtigen Stelle.
Dann sind Länder an der Küste
erstmal vom globalen Internet getrennt.
Das ganze Internet habt ihr damit
natürlich noch nicht zerstört.
Aber es ist ein Anfang.
Aber die Kabel, würde ich mal behaupten,
also auf See kommt man da nicht so einfach hin.
Und dort, wo die rauskommen,
ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich kenne die Station in Hamburg,
wo das Untersee-Kabel rauskommt.
Das kommt da nicht einfach random
an irgendeinem Strand raus,
wo Touristen rumlaufen den ganzen Tag.
Und ob man es einfach so kaputt kriegt
mit einer Axt, ist auch fraglich.
Aber ich gerte, was er sagen will.
Prinzipiell ist es natürlich eine Möglichkeit,
Untersee-Kabel kaputt zu machen.
Ja, aber praktikabel wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich.
Für die, die etwas mehr wollen,
empfehlen wir die fortgeschrittenen Variante.
Die Satelliten-Infrastruktur...
Moment, das ist die dritte Variante?
Was war die erste Variante?
...des Internets.
Also nicht die Satelliten da oben,
das ist eine etwas vertraktere Geschichte.
Wie man damit mischt, dazu haben wir vor ein paar Wochen
ein leider ziemlich gruseliges Video gemacht,
das ihr euch hier ansehen könnt.
Doch zu jedem anständigen Satellitennetz
gehören auch Bodenstationen.
Die sind besser geschützt als die Kabel,
aber ihr könnt von außen den Funkverkehr
mit sogenannten Jammern stören.
Sofern ihr das aber nicht weltweit
mit zig Komplizen genau gleichzeitig macht,
ist das allenfalls ein kleiner Hiccup
im weltweiten Datenfluss.
Wie gesagt, das mit Abstand einfachste
dürfte wirklich sein,
das zu machen, was bisher immer nur
aus Versehen passiert ist,
bei irgendeinem Provider arbeiten
und dort irgendwie BGP-Mist konfigurieren.
Beispielsweise erinnert sich noch einer daran,
das letzte Mal, wo das passiert ist,
da konnten die Leute nicht richtig
auf Teams zugreifen und Office
und sonst was zugreifen.
Und es lag daran,
weil irgendein, ich glaube,
belgischer oder tschechischer
Kunde die AWS-Routen,
wir haben das übrigens nachgebaut
in irgendeinem Stream.
Sollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Irgendwas mit Telekom hieß das.
Wir bauen den Telekom-Ausfall
im Simulator nach, genau.
Da haben wir das doch gemacht, ja.
Ja, da sieht man es doch.
Was habe ich denn da nachgebaut?
DSL-Kunde, Server bei Telekom.
Genau, also das Problem war,
dass irgendein belgischer
oder bulgarischer Provider war es
in dem Fall,
hat ein Netz advertised,
was die Telekom eigentlich
als Netz benutzt
für ihre DSL-Kunden.
Ich glaube, das war das Problem.
Und dann gingen die Sachen
von Azure zurück,
eben nicht mehr hier zum DSL-Provider.
Sondern zum bulgarischen Provider.
Das war, glaube ich,
damals das Problem.
Und ich habe das ja dann auch
irgendwo gezeigt da drinnen.
Genau.
Step by Step.
Ja, genau.
Hier sieht man es.
Also das dürfte wahrscheinlich
die einfachste Variante sein,
wenn man wirklich das Internet
zu größten Teilen kaputt machen will.
Bei einem Provider arbeiten
kann man den PHP-Routen
falsch adverteisen.
Cisco Packet Tracer,
gibt es das noch irgendwo zum Downloaden?
Ja, mittlerweile brauchst du aber
einen Account dafür,
dass du es benutzen kannst.
Was nicht so wild ist,
man konnte sich,
soweit ich weiß,
zumindest zum letzten Mal,
wo ich das benutzt habe,
konnte man den kostenlosen
Net Academy Account machen bei Cisco.
Und dann ging das trotzdem.
Und der sollte sich
für die Profi-Variante entscheiden.
Okay, jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Einen Cyber-Angriff.
Es gibt verschiedene Ideen,
aber bei fast allen
schlägt man das Internet
mit seinen eigenen Waffen.
Denn es besteht aus der Vernetzung
von unzähligen Servern,
auf denen die Daten liegen.
Um dieses Netzwerk geht es
übrigens auch hier.
Nicht um die Löschung von Daten,
die man im Internet findet.
Das Zauberwort heißt Pakete.
Jede Datenmenge,
die durch das Internet geschickt wird,
wird in viele kleine Pakete aufgeteilt.
Um die schnellste Route zu finden,
pingen die Server.
Das heißt,
mithilfe einer Art Testsignal
wird die kürzeste Route errechnet.
Auf diese werden dann die Pakete geschickt.
Was?
Nein!
Kompletter Schwachsinn!
Hä?
Alter, wie kommt man auf sowas?
Um die schnellste Route zu finden,
pingen die Server.
Das heißt,
mithilfe einer Art Testsignal
wird die kürzeste Route errechnet.
Was?
Nicht wirklich, aber okay.
Auf diese werden dann die Pakete geschickt.
Du hast überhaupt keinen Einfluss drauf,
über welche Route
deine Pakete geschickt werden.
Du kannst pingen.
Das bedeutet aber nicht,
dass dein Ping die gleiche Route nimmt
wie andere Pakete.
Dein Server errechnet da schon mal gar nichts.
Es ist nicht so,
dass ich jetzt,
wenn ich ein Paket verschicken will,
irgendwas anpingen kann
und dann dem Paket mitgeben,
wo es lang gehen soll.
Das ist komplett falsch.
Die einzigen Stellen,
wo entschieden wird,
wo ein Paket lang geht,
ist der reinen Lehre nach
von Router zu Router.
In Wirklichkeit ist es nicht so.
Es ist eben so,
welche Gewichte haben welche Route.
Aber das kannst du als jemand,
der Pakete schickt,
überhaupt nicht beeinflussen.
Das Einzige, was du machen kannst,
du schreibst die Ziel-IP in dein Paket
und anhand der Ziel-IP
wird das von Router zu Router
weiter geschoben.
So wie es der jeweilige Router
gerade für richtig hält.
Das hat mit Ping und so gar nichts zu tun.
Ich glaube, er versucht,
Routing-Protokoll zu erklären.
Das macht er, glaube ich, nicht.
Er hat gesagt, es wird gepingt
und anhand dessen wird errechnet,
wo das Paket lang geht.
Das stimmt halt überhaupt nicht.
Und der Server macht das schon mal gar nicht.
Diese Gewichtung der Routen,
das ist Konfigurationssache.
Was übrigens auch eines der Probleme
hier in dem Fall mit der Telekom war,
dass das eine höhere Priorität hatte
in der Route,
dass das DSL-Kundennetz
nach Bulgarien geht
und nicht mehr zur Telekom.
Und wenn es auf einer Route
eine Überlastung gibt
oder ein Server gerade nicht erreichbar ist,
können Pakete einfach
über eine andere Route umgeleitet werden.
Ja, aber es hat trotzdem nichts
mit Ping vom Server auszutun.
An sich also eine super Sache,
die unter anderem so designt wurde,
damit man das Internet eben
nicht einfach so lahmlegen kann.
Das stimmt wiederum.
Wir Idioten wollen das jetzt natürlich trotzdem machen.
Zum Glück sagen manche Forschende,
dass man gerade diese Eigenschaft
in der Telekom hat.
Die Idee bin ich auch als erstes gekommen.
Aber wie gesagt,
es dürfte noch einfacher sein,
sich bei einem Provider zu bewerben
und dort irgendwelche BGP-Sachen zu advertisen.
Weil in der Theorie,
und das hat man jetzt ja auch gesehen,
da wurden ja auch immer ein paar
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergriffen,
dass das nicht mehr so einfach passieren kann,
dass random Provider Netze advertisen,
die ihnen eigentlich gar nicht gehören.
Aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass das immer noch gut funktioniert.
Und dass man da auch
seine eigenen Zwecke nutzen kann.
Es kann eure Heizung mit digitalem Thermostat sein,
eure smarte Zahnbürste,
euer Staubsauger,
vielleicht sogar euer smarter Blumentopf.
Das gibt es heutzutage eigentlich nicht alles.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine der Gefahren,
die potenziell von IoT-Geräten ausgeht.
Gerade wenn die Dinger
bekannte WLAN-Stack-Sicherheitslücken haben
und halt nie Firmenupdates bekommen.
Es gab ja schon IoT-Lampen,
die man theoretisch in Botnets packen konnte.
Ist BGP safe?
Moment, da gibt es eine Website dazu, ja?
Ist BGP safe yet?
No!
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Meistens bekommt man das als Besitzer dieser Geräte
übrigens überhaupt nicht mit,
wenn sie in einer solchen Bot-Armee sind.
Das solltet ihr mal überprüfen.
Wir haben euch hier unter dieser Quelle
eine Website verlinkt,
die beschreibt, wie das geht.
Mithilfe dieses Netzwerkes
und trennt sie.
Mehr dazu findet ihr übrigens in dieser Quelle hier.
Die Server an beiden Enden der Verbindung
sagen nun allen anderen Servern Bescheid,
dass sie gerade mal kurz Kaffee holen sind.
What?
Kurz darauf gehen sie wieder ans Netz
und informieren darüber alle anderen Server.
Das Botnetzwerk trennt die ausgewählte Verbindung wieder.
Jetzt blick ich nicht durch,
was er mir sagen möchte.
Sie verbinden sich, sie trennen sich,
sie verbinden sich.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was es mir gerade sagen soll.
Ich glaube, ihr versteht das Prinzip.
Meint er sowas wie
ganz viele TCP-Verbindungen öffnen
und nie beenden?
Oder was auch immer.
Der Clou bei diesem Gedankenspiel ist,
die Status-Updates häufen sich derart,
dass das System irgendwann
überhaupt nicht mehr in der Lage ist,
die eigentlichen Informationen
durch das Internet zu transportieren.
Ach so, jetzt.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich,
worauf er raus will.
Die Erklärung ist zwar ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ich verstehe nicht,
was er mir sagen will.
Das ist natürlich der Sinn
von jedem Denial-of-Service,
dass du so viel Zeug spammst,
dass das Netzwerk dicht ist.
Und was es halt schwierig macht oftmals ist,
du musst halt unterscheiden zwischen
was ist, nennen wir es mal
Spam-Traffic und was ist echter Traffic,
was du ja so ohne weiteres
auf den ersten Blick gar nicht sagen kannst.
Gerade wenn das so verteilt kommt
wie von IoT-Geräten,
die von irgendwelchen DSL-Anschlüssen
daheim ausgehen,
dann ist es natürlich schwer zu sagen,
okay, das ist jetzt ein legitimer Access
und das nicht.
Was dann gerne gemacht wird,
wenn das soweit ist,
dann wird dann irgendwelche Captures
davor geschaltet oder sowas
oder durch Cloudflare durchgeschleift
oder was auch immer.
Aber das ist tatsächlich
und hilft aber in der Regel
natürlich nur
einige Services.
Weil es ist jetzt nicht so,
als hätten wir da 100.000 Botnetze,
die die Kapazität haben,
sagen wir mal jetzt
Microsoft, Google
und alle größeren Anbieter
gleichzeitig lahmzulegen.
Das stimmt Chat,
das ist nicht zwangsläufig so,
aber das ist die verbreiteste Variante.
Man kann natürlich auch,
wenn man den Service kennt,
besonders viel Last
im Backend verursachen zum Beispiel.
Gibt unterschiedliches an.
Aber voll Spammen mit Traffic
ist auf jeden Fall die verbreitetste
und gängigste Variante.
Wie man das mit dem Traffic erreicht,
sind natürlich auch wieder
unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Es war eine ganze Zeit lang
sowas wie DNS Amplification
relativ beliebt.
Aber es gibt mehrere Varianten.
Aber eine Sache haben viele Angriffe
gemein
und das ist auch der Grund,
warum sowas wie DNS Amplification
relativ beliebt war.
Du brauchst nur einen kleinen,
eine kleine Anzahl
beziehungsweise kleine Datenmenge,
um das auszulösen,
um viel Traffic und hohe Datenmenge
beim eigentlichen Ziel zu produzieren.
Ich kann euch das,
ich kann euch das mal ganz kurz,
ohne zu sehr in Details zu erklären,
gehen und versuchen zu erklären.
Und zwar,
wenn man DNS Anfragen macht,
das geht ja schlechthin.
Aber wenn man zum Beispiel
DNS Anfragen macht,
schicken wir mal eine DNS Anfrage.
Schicken wir mal eine DNS Anfrage hier.
Dick!
WoplosTV at Cloudflare.
So, da kriegt man diese Antwort.
Und man kann bei DNS Anfragen
auch noch ein paar Optionen mitschicken,
dass man größere Antworten kriegt.
Also, eine coole Sache
bei DNS Anfragen ist,
DNS Anfragen ist die Anfrage
relativ klein,
die Antwort relativ groß.
Wie ihr hier schon sehen könnt,
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal,
keine Ahnung, google.com oder so anfragt,
manchmal gibt es ja auch mehrere Antworten.
Also, man sieht schon,
die Anfrage ist relativ klein,
die Antwort ist relativ groß.
Man kann dann auch viel mehr,
noch viel größere Antworten provozieren.
Und was ich jetzt machen kann,
ist Folgendes.
Ich schicke DNS Anfragen
mit einer gefakten Absender-IP.
Also mal angenommen,
ich will einen Dienst D-Dossen.
Wie gesagt, DNS Amplification
ist gar nicht mehr so beliebt mittlerweile,
aber es ist ein schönes Beispiel,
um das der Hand zu demonstrieren.
Also mal angenommen,
ich will einen Dienst D-Dossen.
Ich habe aber selbst jetzt nicht
so die ultra-fette Leitung,
um den einfach dicht machen zu können.
Und, naja, Anleitung.
Ich erkläre ja einfach nur,
wie es theoretisch funktioniert.
Dann würde man DNS Anfragen schicken.
Beispielsweise an den
Cloudflare DNS
mit gefakte Absender-IP.
Und
die gefakte Absender-IP
ist halt die IP des Dienstes,
den ich angreifen will.
Und dann bekommt er
ganz viele DNS Responses quasi.
Also ich sage dem DNS Server,
Hallo, was ist denn hier
die IP von google.com?
Allerdings habe ich die Absender-IP gefälscht,
sodass die Antwort zurück,
und die Antwort ist halt deutlich größer
als die Anfrage,
dass sie dann zurückgeht
zu dem Dienst, den ich angreifen will.
Das heißt, ich kann mit relativ wenig
Bandbreite bei mir
relativ viel Bandbreite
erzeugen
beim Ziel.
Deswegen ist das eine Sache,
natürlich ist das nicht so einfach,
wie ich es jetzt erklärt habe.
Und man macht es auch nicht
mit einem einfachen Kommandozeilenbefehl.
Da gehört noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Aber das ist so die grobe Idee dahinter.
Allgemein sind so Amplification-Sachen
recht beliebt
aus diesen Gründen.
So, weiter geht's.
Es ist also effektiv lahmgelegt.
Eine andere Angriffsmethode
mit so einem Bot-Netzwerk
hat es tatsächlich schon mal gegeben.
Am 21. Oktober 2002.
Da haben Hacker die 13 DNS-Root-Server
des Internets angegriffen.
Gut, das waren auch andere Zeiten.
Die sind quasi das
Adressbuch des Internets.
Aber die Adressen sind schwer zu merken.
Kepplalan 1-2202-az-Nord-Wijk-Niederlande
zum Beispiel.
Oder war das 2-2-0-2?
Bei IP-Adressen ist es sogar noch schwieriger.
Daher haben Websites Namen.
www.drwatson.shop
ist zum Beispiel eine ganz besonders tolle.
Oder www.wikipedia.org.
Habt ihr davon schon mal gehört?
Diese DNS-Root-Server
übersetzen die Adresse, die wir eingeben,
in die entsprechende IP.
Sprich, ohne diese Server
kommt man nicht an, wo es hin soll.
Im Oktober 2002.
Ist zwar verkehrt,
aber man weiß, was er sagen will.
Ich will ja nicht pipslicher sein als der Papst.
Bombardierten Hacker sie 75 Minuten lang
mit derart vielen Anfragen,
dass 9 von 13
Aber 2002 war wirklich auch
noch eine andere Zeit, was das angeht.
überlastet waren.
Sie konnten keine tatsächlichen Anfragen
mehr beantworten.
Ziemlich effektiv.
Aber zugegeben, dauerhaft lahmgelegt
Wie gesagt, ich bleib dabei.
Das Einfachste dürfte wirklich,
also wenn man viel, viel
Stress anrichten will,
so im großen Stil
und nichts Illegales machen will,
in dem Sinn, das Einfachste wäre
wahrscheinlich wirklich,
sich bei einem Provider zu bewerben
und aus Versehen irgendwelche
BGP-Sachen falsch zu konfigurieren.
Sendung mit der Maus,
wie das Internet funktioniert.
Echt, die haben sowas?
Das ist bestimmt gut.
Hier Methode Nummer 4.
Internet zerstören für Diktatoren
und alle anderen Staaten.
Also, ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass der Typ, der sich aus Versehen
verkonfiguriert hat,
beim bulgarischen Provider
große Probleme bekommen hat.
Wie funktioniert das Internet?
Das muss ich mir auch noch
angucken gleich.
Damit könntet ihr das Internet
in einem ganzen Land abschalten.
Dafür müsstet ihr allerdings,
wie der Name schon sagt,
wahrscheinlich auch kein
besonders netter Typ sein.
Dann könntet ihr nämlich einfach
den Internet-Service-Providern
eures Landes befehlen,
euer Land vom globalen Internet
zu trennen.
Und wenn nicht, werden sie
mit der Flak abgeballert,
Nordkorea-Style.
Und dann ist das Internet
in eurem Land wirklich
für so lange, wie ihr wollt,
tot.
So in Teilen passiert im Iran
aber egal.
Wenn man wirklich richtig effektiv
und auf einen Schlag
das gesamte Internet ausschalten
wollen würde,
dann greift man am besten
das Stromnetz ran.
Danke fürs Zuhören
und der heutige TED-Talk
zum Thema...
Okay, aber wie gesagt,
die beste Methode
mit manipulierten PGP-Routen
ist nicht dabei gewesen.
Das dürfte auch das
wie das Internet funktioniert.
Oder der Elefant erklärt es uns.
Alter, wie alt ist denn der Beitrag schon?
Ist das ein Netscape
oder Internet Explorer
oder Netzcape?
Das Internet Explorer.
Das ist von 2001
oder so ein Beitrag.
Oder noch älter.
Wahrscheinlich eher 1998 oder so.
Sun Server, ja.
Und diese graue Kiste
Okay, Leute.
Das ist ja mal richtig oldschool, Alter.
Parallel Ports, Serial Ports
und alles.
Geil.
Da lief bestimmt noch Solaris drauf.
SCSI oder SCSI
wie es manche nennen.
Also PS2 sehe ich jetzt hier nicht.
Wo ist PS2, Leute?
Ach, das hier.
Das hier ist ein PS2-Anschluss,
tatsächlich, ja.
Übrigens, Leute,
es könnte durchaus sein,
dass das hier,
das ist die Verbindung zum Storage, oder?
Kann das sein?
Storage-Verbindung, hier ist Storage
und hier ist der Anschluss für Storage.
Meint ihr, das könnte sein?
Storage-Verbindung, SCSI-Storage?
Battle-Bit.
Spielen wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich ein paar Runden.
Interessant.
Das rote Kabel.
Die gute Zeiten von Big Towers damals.
Wichtig, ganz wichtig,
muss rot sein, ja.
Modem.
Echt?
Es heißt der Modem?
Wirklich?
Siehste mal,
bei der Maus lernt man noch was.
Ich habe gerade so ein Modem.
Das ist ein Modem.
Bei der Maus lernt man noch was.
Ich habe gerade so ein Modem.
Das muss ich mit dem Strom verbinden.
Dann einen zweiten Stecker hinten an meinen Rechner.
Serial-Anschluss, ja.
In die Telefonstecker.
Kabelmäßig, alles klar.
Jetzt brauche ich noch eine CD mit einem Programm.
Das muss ich auf meinem Rechner installieren.
Das Programm bekomme ich von einem Provider.
Davon gibt es viele.
Provider heißt Lieferant, Hersteller
und der Provider hilft mir dabei,
die Mausseite im Internet zu finden.
Das habe ich ja schon wieder komplett verdrängt.
RealPlayer.
Guck mal, RealPlayer wird installiert.
Damals, ja, gab es auch noch.
Da hat man dann so ein kleines Fenster gehabt,
wo irgendwelche Videos drin liefen.
Im Internet zu finden.
Wie macht er das?
Der Provider hat auch einen Riesenrechner,
der mit dem Internet verbunden ist.
Alles hinten voller Kabel.
Man begreift gar nicht, was da vor sich geht.
Guck mal, Glasfaserstecker.
LC oder SC?
Ich kann es mir immer nicht merken,
was die großen Stecker sind.
SC sind die großen, glaube ich, gell?
LC?
Ach, fuck, ich kann es immer nicht merken.
LC, SC, Stecker.
Nee, SC sind die großen, sage ich doch.
Nee, oder?
Was ist das hier für ein Stecker?
LC-Stecker, doch.
Nee, SC.
Nee, das ist ein SC-Stecker,
da habe ich recht, SC.
Ich bringe das auch immer durcheinander
mit Large und Small,
aber das heißt es ja überhaupt nicht.
Das ist Local und Subscriber.
Genau, SC sind das.
Das sind SC.
Guck mal, das sind auch eindeutig
die großen, viereckigen.
Ein Provider?
Und weil ich das Programm installiert habe,
bin ich jetzt bei dem Kunde
und jetzt gehe ich zum Provider hin.
Guten Tag.
Na klar.
Jetzt machen sie quasi Modem-Einwahl.
Alles in Ordnung.
Das ging damals über Pub und Chub und sowas noch,
oder war das bei DSL?
War das bei Modem gar nicht so?
Der hat eine Maus auf dem Kopf, ja.
Zwei Zimmer kriege ich,
damit er mich später wiederfinden kann.
In Wirklichkeit geht es natürlich
alles von zu Hause von meinem Rechner.
Da schreibe ich auch meinen Namen rein.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht erklärt,
wisst ihr das?
Das ist echt nicht übel.
Darunter dann mein Kennwort,
auch wieder Frika-L in dem Fall,
und dann drücke ich auf eine Taste.
Dann sage ich meinem Computer
bitte sprich mit dem Provider.
blblblblblbl
Und jetzt wird das Modem wichtig. Das übersetzt meine Anfrage in hörbare Töne, die der Provider
entschlüsseln kann. Dann passiert genau das gleiche wie eben. Mein Name und mein Kennwort
werden überprüft. Merke ich nichts von. Dann kriegt mein Rechner eine Wartenummer
und dann fragt der Provider, was ich will.
Was darf es denn sein? Ich hätte gerne die Homepage von der Maus.
Alles klar. Warten Sie einen Moment. Ich rufe Sie auf. Sie haben die Nummer 4.
Jetzt fängt der Provider an zu arbeiten und ich kann nichts weiter tun, als zu warten.
Der Provider findet mich wieder. Ich habe ja die Wartenummer 4. In Wirklichkeit bin
ich natürlich nicht im Laden, sondern mache das einmal.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich sagen, er hat eine externe IP, quasi 4 und da klickt er dann
die Antwort halt zurückgeschickt. Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz richtig, aber die Erklärung
ist nicht verkehrt. Also die ist nicht schlecht gemacht.
Meinem Rechner. Ich spreche nicht mit dem Provider, sondern ich gebe den Namen ein,
was ich suche. Da steht zwar Adresse, aber trotzdem muss ich einen Namen reintippen.
HTTP sagt, um welchen Teil des Internets es sich handelt.
www.wdr. Ja, streng genommen natürlich nicht richtig, aber okay.
Mauspunkt ist der Name des Rechners, wo sich die Mausseite befindet und die sagt,
dass der Rechner in Deutschland angemeldet ist. Ja, ja, und diese Anfrage übersetzt
das Modem genau wie eben wieder in diese hörbaren Töne.
Ja, nur dass man es nicht hört die ganze Zeit. Glücklicherweise weiß der Provider,
was ich sehen will. Er weiß, dass die Mausseite auf irgendeinem Rechner in Deutschland steht,
aber er kennt noch nicht seine Adresse und deswegen schreibt er sowas. Ähnliches wie ein Brief.
Eine Nachricht zur Auskunft.
Gibt es jetzt DNS oder was gibt das? Ist das jetzt DNS?
Wenn man die Adresse nicht weiß, schickt er jemanden zur Auskunft.
Wie hat man sich das vorzustellen?
Weil er die Adresse nicht weiß, schickt er jemanden zur Auskunft.
Wie hat man sich das vorzustellen? Wenn man mit dem Herrn Schmitz telefonieren will und weiß seine
Telefonnummer nicht, ruft man die Telefonauskunft an. Und beim Internet ruft man eben die
Internetauskunft an. Und die sitzt in Frankfurt.
Das ist natürlich auch wieder nur so ein blöder Computer.
Und was passiert da drin? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Das ist so, als wenn da ein Typ säße, der alle Adressen aller Rechner,
die es in Deutschland gibt, kennt.
Aha, neue Adresse.
Der Auskunftsmann schaut dann in seinen Karteikästen nach und sucht die richtige
Adresse zum Namen der Maushomepage. Die eigentliche Adresse ist eine
Zahlenkombination. Warum ist das so? Computer können nur mit Zahlen umgehen.
Wir Menschen können uns natürlich leichter einen Namen merken als so eine
krumme Zahlenkombination. Und deswegen verknüpft der Auskunftscomputer den
Namen mit der richtigen Zahlenkombination und schickt die zurück zum Provider.
Wenn der die Adresse hat, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Wenn das eine Seite ist, die häufig angefordert wird, hat er sich davon eine
Kopie gemacht und kann den Kunden direkt von seinem Laden aus bedienen.
Das ist aber eine neue Seite und deswegen kommt Möglichkeit Nummer zwei.
Er muss sich die Mausseite aus dem WDR Rechner besorgen und schickt eine neue
Nachricht. Eine Nachricht zum WDR Rechner.
Der Provider weiß jetzt, wo er die Mausseite findet.
Die Nachricht ist auf dem Weg. Sie weiß auch, wo sie hin muss, aber noch nicht.
Also die Erklärung gibt es gibt eigentlich nichts zu beanstanden.
Besten Weg dahin.
Deswegen ist sie unterwegs immer darauf angewiesen, dass sie jemand sagt, wo sie
hin muss.
Da musst du lang.
Jetzt wird jetzt wird geroutet.
Guck, das ist nicht schlecht gemacht.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Vor allem vor allem.
Sie erzählen das auch wirklich richtig.
Der sagt dem Router, wo er hin will.
Der sagt dem Router nicht irgendwas von DNS oder sein.
Der sagt dem Ich will dahin.
Und der Router sagt ihm nur eine Sache, wo es zum nächsten Router geht.
Wo ist weiter? Der nächste Hop.
Wer sagt er dem? Das ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Man sagt, wo sie hin muss.
Da musst du lang. Das sind Computer, die nennt man Router.
Das ist sowas wie Wegweiser.
Und noch eine andere Funktion haben die.
Wenn irgendwo mal ein Rechner abgeschaltet ist oder wenn eine Leitung
zusammengebrochen ist, dann leiten die Router die Nachricht um.
Da geht's nicht lang.
Das ist die Leitung zusammengebrochen.
Das ist dann zwar ein Umweg, aber trotzdem die schnellste Möglichkeit.
Das ist echt gut gemacht.
Und so kommt es, dass obwohl ich als auch der Provider und der WDR in Köln
sitzen, meine Anfrage nach der Maus hat einen Umweg durch halb Deutschland
machen muss. Aber das ist eben das Internet.
So sieht übrigens so ein Router aus, der meine Anfrage durchs Internet führt.
Was hat man da gesehen? Ich habe nur Kabel gesehen.
Ah, da haben sie von irgendeinem Rack hinten ein paar Bilder gemacht.
Die Einschubdinger, die sehen heute immer noch so aus.
Die Kabel nicht. Das sind keine PNC Kabel oder was auch immer.
Aber von den Einschub von der Bauweise sehen die Dinger heute immer noch
erstaunlich ähnlich aus.
Übrigens so ein Router aus, der meine Anfrage durchs Internet führt.
Und schließlich ist sie beim WDR Rechner angekommen.
Der erkennt jetzt, dass ich Armin mit der Warte Nr.
4 gerne die Maus Homepage sehen möchte.
Und dann kramt der Rechner in seinen elektronischen Daten rum,
macht eine Kopie von, was zur Maus Homepage gehört, so nach dem Motto.
Macht davon für mich eine Kopie und schickt die zurück an den Provider.
Schreibt außen drauf, das ist für Armin Warte Nr.
4. Und dann läuft die Homepage durch das gesamte Spinnennetz
von Rechnern und Computern zurück zum Provider quer durch ganz Deutschland.
Übrigens, die haben eine Sache richtig gut gemacht.
Das erwähnen die ja gar nicht.
Fällt euch auf, dass der Weg zurück nicht der Weg ist,
den sie hingegangen sind.
Das kann auch so wirklich so sein.
Jetzt von Rechnern und Computern zurück zum Provider
quer durch ganz Deutschland bedeutet nicht, dass sie auf dem gleichen Weg
zurückkommt.
Oh, die sagen sogar.
Ja, und weil da die Nummer 4 draufsteht, kriege ich jetzt endlich
meine Maus Seite.
Weht es eh an?
Na ja, danke und tschüss.
Auf Wiedersehen.
So, nun habe ich's endlich.
Meine Maus Seite, die Homepage von der Maus
und die ganzen Geschichten mit dem Laden, wo man hingehen muss
und mit den ganzen Gängen, durch die da die Leute flitzen.
Das haben wir uns nur ausgedacht, um euch in etwa zu zeigen,
was da so alles im Hintergrund passiert.
In Wirklichkeit geht es natürlich alles von zu Hause aus,
vom eigenen Rechner und geht ganz schnell.
Das Ganze passiert eigentlich in wenigen Sekunden.
Man muss nur den richtigen Namen eingeben und alles andere
machen die Computer untereinander aus.
Die Verbindung aufbauen, die Adresse rausfinden,
die Nachrichten verschicken und kopieren.
Ich merke nur, dass in ein paar Sekunden die Mausseite bei mir
auf dem Rechner ist.
Jetzt guckt man, die haben damals auch schon GIFs verwendet.
Hätte damals jemand gesagt 2023 sind GIFs immer noch der heiße Scheiß,
dann hätte man sich ausgelacht.
Gibt's aber noch was Besonderes.
Da sind so manche Bildchen drin, auf denen was zappelt.
Und jedes Mal, wenn man da draufklickt, geht das gleiche Spiel von vorne los.
Hinter jedem dieser Zappelbildchen warten nämlich noch jede Menge Überraschungen.
Was das ist, beraten wir jetzt nicht.
Das könnt ihr ja selbst mal ausprobieren.
Das war wirklich mal ein gutes Video zu dem Thema.
Dafür bezahle ich doch gerne Gebühren, auch wenn er schon 20 Jahre alt ist
oder wahrscheinlich noch älter, 25 Jahre alt ist.
Ist die Seite noch live?
Was war? Wie war die Seite?
WDR Maus oder?
Die Namen eingeben und alles andere.
WDR Maus Punkt D.
Ja, die gibt's, aber das ist etwas leicht moderner.
Wir können mal kurz gucken,
wenn wir gerade dabei sind, Archiv Org.
Ach nee, Moment, ich bin falsch.
Okay, ja, okay.
Die ersten die ersten Einträge gibt es 2000.
Okay, mehr gibt's da anscheinend nicht.
Okay, wow.
Ach hier, jetzt doch.
Ja, das ist die Seite.
Guck mal, liebe Maus Surfer und Maus Surferinnen,
wir hoffen, ihr hattet viel Spaß auf dem ARD Kinderfest in Essen.
Oh ja, genau.
Kann man nicht wegklicken.
Damals war halt die Auflösung von der Webseite, die war eher so.
Ja, man hat das neben gar nicht gesehen.
So 640 mal 480.
Ja gut, gibt's noch.
Alles klar.
Wo sind die Augen auf der rechten Seite?
Ich gehe davon aus, die sind dafür da,
wenn du halt eine höhere Auflösung hattest,
dass dann nicht einfach weiß ist.
Die Seite war bestimmt hart.
Leute, warte mal, warte mal, wartet mal.
Eine Sache will ich mir noch angucken.
Ihr wartet mal, wartet mal.
View Page Source.
Guck mal hier.
Für Explorer kennt es nicht.
Guck mal, da wurde da wurde schon ein bisschen Javascript gejavascriptet.
Von J.Segers.
1998 wurde das Java gescriptet.
Unix Timestamp.
Fernbeet?
Fernbett?
Play Multimedia, fliegender Ball.
Begrenzung.
Was? Ich gleich Harald?
Was?
Ich gleich Harald?
Okay, eine Seite.
Innere Tabelle.
Damals wurden Webseiten-Layouts noch mit Tabellen gemacht.
Ja, so ist richtig.
Schalter, Sendung on.
Das war noch, das waren ja
Ursprünge der Web-Entwicklung.
Aber das HTML ist nicht von Hand gebaut, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt mit Dreamweaver gebaut oder sowas.
Wobei, dann wären nicht die Comments da drinne.
Vielleicht ist es doch von Hand gebaut.
Ja, wo ist das Problem?
Nesting Rules.
Lul, das hat die da nicht interessiert.
Als Zeilente.
File Archived.
Achso, nee, das ist
das Internet Archive.
Ja, so sah die Source Code der Mouse-Website damals aus.
Ebene 1.
Beste, beste.
So musst du es machen.
Heute immer noch.
Best Practice.
Einfach die komplette Seite absolut positionieren.
Fertig, aus.
Ach nee, das ist der Ball.
So eine Art Overlay.
Welcher Ball auch immer
damit gemeint ist,
der Zukunftsreporter.
Ja.
No Photoshop.
Das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Ja, so sah die Mouse-Webseite aus 2000.
Wilder Kram, ne?
Das war entweder Dreamweaver oder Frontpage.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es Dreamweaver, wann gab es dann?
Wann gab es denn den Kram schon?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das gab es 2000.
Ja, ja, 1997.
Und Frontpage?
95, okay.
Weil ich sag euch,
Macromedia Dreamweaver.
Damit habe ich damals Webseiten gemacht
und die hatten schon Autocomplete und sowas für Javascript, HTML.
Das war richtig advanced damals, so Dreamweaver 7 oder
Dreamweaver MX.
Ja, genau.
So sah das damals aus.
Ja, ja.
Ja, da hatte man schon
schon Javascript, CSS, HTML, Autocomplete.
Das war richtig advanced da.
Das war noch nicht Adobe, das war Macromedia damals.
Die haben das erst später gekauft.
Ich bin übrigens gar nicht sicher,
ob es Dreamweaver überhaupt überhaupt noch gibt.
Okay, das gibt es anscheinend immer noch.
Es ist halt die große Frage, warum sollte man das verwenden?
In der heutigen Zeit macht jetzt irgendwie nicht so wahnsinnig Sinn.
Aber das war echt nice damals, Dreamweaver.
Visual Studio Code, beste.
Einfach Visual Studio Code, fertig.
Das bringt out of the box alles mit, was man braucht.
Und es gibt tausende Plugins, wo man sogar noch erweilt.
Brackets, ja.
Das ist leider eingestellt mittlerweile,
soweit ich weiß.
Das war auch eine coole Idee.
Das war ein Editor von Adobe für mit Live Preview von Webseiten
und sowas. Eigentlich ganz coole Sache.
Klar, Java gab es noch früher.
Nee, nee, nee.
Java gibt es richtig lang.
Java Release Date.
Ja, 1996.
Es gibt schon richtig lang.
Java Version History.
Januar 1996.
Witzig, es gibt heute immer noch Sachen, die JDK 7 oder so verwenden.
Und das ist eigentlich 12 Jahre alt.
Ach so, ja gut, aktuell.
Was ist, was ist Azul, Leute?
Was ist, hä?
Hat irgendjemand Ahnung, was das ist?
Azul, Linux oder was?
Azul JDK, Zulul.
Welches Legacy Zeug?
Ist das nicht ein Minecraft YouTuber?
Ja, bestimmt. Bestimmt wird das ein Minecraft YouTuber sein.
Wer das noch supportet.
Aber kann sein, dass es auch einen gibt, der so heißt.
Ja, ich kenne mich da nicht so aus.
Wie hieß noch das Office Paket von Sun?
Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Das ist der Vorgänger von Open Office war das.
Star Office, oder?
War das Star Office?
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Nee, das war was anderes.
Staroffice.com, Moment.
Warte mal, die Webseite gibt es noch.
Warum um alles in der Welt sollte man das denn noch benutzen?
Sun, ja doch, Star Office, dann meine ich das.
Ja, Star Office.
Das war gar nicht mal so kacke damals.
What? Das ist Libre Office hier.
Star Office.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern?
Ersten Computer, den ich hatte.
Das war ein...
Nee, Moment, warte mal, warte mal, war das der erste?
Ich glaube ja.
Das ist mein erster Computer, war ein Pentium 90.
Ich glaube mit 16 MB RAM und 1,2 G Festplatte.
Das war damals richtig krasses Ding.
Und 0,7 G Festplatte, irgendwie sowas.
Und da war Star Office dabei.
Windows 95, Star Office.
Ich fand das damals gar nicht übel.
Mach mal was Cooles für Kanalpunkte.
Ja, hast du eine gute Idee?
Ich habe keine.
Ihr könntet mich ja auch mal ans Trinken erinnern.
Ich habe lange nichts mehr getrunken.
Jetzt habe ich gerade ja schon was.
Stellanzeige...
Okay, das könnten wir echt reinmachen.
Dafür war die Turbo Taste nicht da.
Die Turbo Taste war dafür da, um den Rechner langsamer zu machen.
Das ist ein weit verbreiteter Irrglaube.
Wahrscheinlich der Sache geschuldet, dass viele Leute,
die das heute vom Namen her kennen, damals nicht dabei waren.
Die Turbo Taste war dafür da, den Rechner langsamer zu machen.
Weil damals viele Software und gerade Spiele
halt angepasst waren auf den Takt vom Rechner
und nicht irgendwie nach Uhrzeit oder Clock
oder sonstigen Sachen gearbeitet haben, sondern halt nach Ticks.
Und dann liefen Spiele unspielbar schnell teilweise.
Deswegen hast du die Turbo Taste rausgemacht,
dass der Rechner langsamer lief.
Es war keine Übertaktungstaste oder sowas.
Ich glaube, Dark Souls hat das nicht gebraucht.
Das gab es ja da noch nicht.
Aber dann wäre natürlich, wäre natürlich nicer Hack gewesen,
alles in Zeitlupe zu spielen.
Dark Souls ist Framebound.
Ja, Framebound ist nicht das gleiche wie
auf die Taktfrequenz von der CPU.
Framebound heißt ja im Endeffekt nur, wenn es mehr als 30 FPS laufen lässt,
ist es im Arsch.
Ja gut, im Prinzip aber schon, wenn das mit mehr FPS rendert.
Ja, und es nicht gecapped war.
Also ich habe damals Kommandos gespielt.
Das war ja, kennt das noch einer?
Kommandos Game?
Es war ein richtig, richtig nice Taktik, Taktik Game.
Und da gab es, da gab es damals eine Mission.
Ja, genau, da gab es damals eine Mission,
da sind so Boote patrouilliert auf dem, auf dem Fluss
und auf meinem neuen Rechner konnte man das nicht spielen.
Normalerweise ging der Ausguck,
der Ausguck von dem Boot hat sich halt dann so gedreht, so im Endeffekt so.
Und auf meinem Rechner, wo ich das Spiel gespielt habe,
hat sich der Ausguck vom Boot so gedreht.
Konnte es das Game nicht spielen.
Aber Kommandos, Kommandos war ein mega Game.
Richtig geiles Game.
Und auch schwer es fuck.
Es gab damals, es gab damals irgendwie Tricks,
dass man das Game limitieren konnte und sowas.
Das war aber damals halt nicht drauf ausgelegt, dass auf einmal,
dass man auf einmal zwei Jahre später einen Rechner hatte,
der fünfmal so schnell war.
Hallo zusammen, ich habe folgendes Problem,
ich habe mir zweimal eine AMD GPU gekauft.
Ich habe massive Artifacting, könnte auch potenziell sein.
Also Artefakte liegt meistens eher an kaputten im RAM,
weniger am Netzteil.
Aber ist es nicht so, als hätte ich da jetzt wahnsinnig Ahnung von
beziehungsweise als kann man das Remote ordentlich diagnostizieren?
Netzteil eher nicht.
Vielleicht eher Grafikkarten RAM, ja.
Okay, Leute, jetzt gehe ich aber wirklich was futtern.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Bis denn. Vielleicht heute Abend ein paar Runden Battle Bit.
Wir haben Half-Life schon fertig durchgespielt.
Hast du verpasst wahrscheinlich.
Bis denn. Macht's gut.
C U.